[Música]
hola soy alan austria y les doy la
bienvenida a este especial de noticias
donde a partir de este momento y por las
próximas dos horas y media aquí en
france24 vamos a llevarles toda la
información y el análisis de la segunda
jornada de la convención nacional
demócrata que comenzó ayer y termina
este jueves para ello iremos en unos
momentos con nuestros corresponsales en
nueva york washington y california y
además tendremos el análisis de julio
healing estratega republicano rodolfo
por estratega demócrata y rafael piñeros
profesor de relaciones internacionales
esta convención demócrata en la que se
confirmará oficialmente a joe biden como
el candidato presidencial del partido se
celebra por primera vez en casi 200 años
de historia de manera virtual debido a
la pandemia del cob y 19 veamos lo que
se espera hoy los oradores principales
serán jill biden la esposa del virtual
candidato el ex presidente bill clinton
la congresista alexandra ocasio cortez y
el ex secretario de estado john kerry la
jornada de ayer estuvo marcada por un
llamado a la unión a todos los espectros
del partido demócrata
intervenciones del senador bernie
sanders y la ex primera dama michelle
obama el gobernador de nueva york andrew
cuomo y otros demócratas de alto perfil
inauguraron esta convención lanzando
fuertes críticas a la presidencia actual
y pidiendo un cambio de liderazgo la
gestión de trump de la pandemia del cob
y 19 la lucha contra el racismo
acompañada por las palabras de la
familia del afroamericano georg floyd
quien falleció en custodia policial
despertó una ola de protestas así como
la controversia frente al servicio
postal y el voto por correo todo esto
fueron los principales temas del primer
día
donald trump reaccionó respondió al
discurso de michelle obama y dijo que él
si llego a la casa blanca fue por culpa
de la gestión del ex presidente barack
obama el mandatario también se ha
embarcado de nuevo en un viaje de
campaña y de cara a las elecciones
presidenciales rompiendo con las
tradicionales en las que los candidatos
tienden a manejar un bajo perfil cuando
se celebra la convención del partido
opositor
que alguien por favor le expliqué
michelle obama que donald trump no
estaría aquí en la hermosa casa blanca
si no fuera por el trabajo realizado por
su esposo barack obama y comenzamos las
intervenciones con nuestra corresponsal
en washington buenas noches por allá en
la capital estadounidense diana
castañeda ayer lo decíamos fue una
convención de aspecto y sonido diferente
que resalta desde el primer día y qué
podemos esperar hoy en la que el tema
central del programa es el liderazgo
hola qué tal así es el día de ayer
veíamos como el llamado principal del
partido demócrata en esta primera
jornada de la convención era a la unidad
no solamente para que se unieran los
votantes demócratas y salieran a votar
ya fuera de manera presencial oa través
del correo pero también para que se
unieran todos apoyar a joe biden y es
que el líderes importantes del partido
como el senador bernie sanders quien
estaba también lanzándose por la
candidatura pues tienen gran apoyo de
los latinos un gran apoyo de los
afroamericanos de las uniones laborales
y de trabajadores en todo el país así
que esperan que ese apoyo de estar la
más progresista se vea traducido en las
urnas lo que no ocurrió en la
candidatura de hillary clinton el día de
hoy veremos un tema central que es el
liderazgo el liderazgo de joe biden es
algo que va a resaltar en su discurso su
esposa que será el discurso central
hablar
de cómo ha logrado construir su carrera
pero también las dificultades que ha
tenido al interior de su familia y que
lo han convertido en el líder que es
también veremos otros líderes
importantes del partido republicano como
el ex presidente cárter también veremos
al ex presidente bill clinton
hablando sobre esas cualidades que tiene
no solamente no valen sino también su
fórmula vicepresidencial harris así que
ese será el tema central y por supuesto
también veremos más testimonios de
ciudadanos sobre cómo ha mostrado según
lo ha revelado el programa del partido
demócrata como ha mostrado el presidente
de donald trump poco liderazgo para
lidiar con la pandemia donde hay 40
millones de personas que han solicitado
subsidios al desempleo con un
crecimiento económico que no se veía en
décadas y que tiene digamos a muchas
personas fuera de sus lugares de trabajo
así que esto es lo que se espera para la
jornada del día de hoy y conocer un poco
más de lo que es joe biden
en su carrera y cómo podría liderar el
país si llega a ganar el próximo 9 de
noviembre 3 bien a una pregunta más
contigo antes de ir con nuestros
invitados y especialistas el mensaje de
ayer fue unánime
hoy será igual todos duro contra trump
no se manejara pues un tono más suave
el lenguaje sigue siendo el digamos
fuerte como lo vimos el día de ayer y es
lo que hemos visto también en el
adelanto que han dado el partido
demócrata para lo que serán estos tres
días que quedan de convención porque hay
diferentes hechos que han marcado
particularmente este año en la
administración del presidente de donald
son no sólo el manejo de la pandemia
como lo mencionábamos también el manejo
que dio a las protestas frente a
justicia racial en diferentes estados
del país respondiendo con gases
lacrimógenos
también ayer veíamos por ejemplo a
michelle obama asegurando que cada vida
de cada ciudadano en los eeuu es
importante no son cifras nada más las
personas que están muriendo durante la
pandemia y que por eso digamos está la
razón por la cual los demócratas tienen
este lenguaje tan fuerte sobre todo
cuando el presidente de donald trump
está adelantando una campaña en donde
está poniendo en cuestionamiento
si será efectivo o no votar a través del
servicio postal a través de correo y
generando de nuevo digamos estas
tácticas que vimos también en su campaña
a la presidencia hace cuatro años atrás
ya nada vamos a seguir contigo en el
transcurso del programa especial del día
de hoy momento de hablar con los
especialistas vamos a empezar con rafael
piñeros él es profesor de relaciones
internacionales y también analista de
problemas políticos contemporáneos
muchas gracias profesor por estar con
nosotros nos gustaría empezar hablando
del momento de mayor interés
latinoamericano el día de hoy usted lo
identifica como en el espacio de tiempo
corto que va a tener la representante
alexandra ocasio cortez
buenas noches y gracias por la
invitación sin duda alguna el hecho de
que alexandra ocasio cortes esté en la
convención demócrata será un hito
importante por su ascendencia latina hoy
el mensaje central es conocer a un
candidato y lo hace a partir de una
joven figura una joven figura que lleva
dos años un poco menos de dos años en el
congreso de los estados unidos
representando al estado de nueva york en
la cámara baja y sin duda alguna tiene
un desafío fundamental y es hacer
entender que a pesar de las diferencias
que hubiese podido haber entre el
candidato que ella apoyaba que era
bernie sanders y él
como el partido
7 es una víctima
de alexandra cortes no creo que sea un
discurso de la emotividad o del
conflicto que ella suele observar en la
sociedad sino un elemento más de por qué
confiar en yo
como un candidato que tiene la
posibilidad de rotar a donald trump en
noviembre de 2020 muy bien profesor
piñero vamos a estar también checando
algunos problemas de comunicación que
tuvimos con usted pero seguimos no los
soltamos ahora vamos con el politólogo
julio chilín él es estratega republicano
y él nos gustaría preguntarle en
específico si al estar ya definido que
joe biden es la apuesta demócrata este
evento logrará despertar un mayor
interés un menor interés en las
celebraciones de este año comparado con
las convenciones pasadas
saludos al es un placer estar contigo y
con france 24 en esta noche el
presidente de down ron va a ganar
abrumadoramente por la realidad que está
viviendo los eeuu lo que estamos viendo
en este momento es en realidad una farsa
para intentar de engañar al pueblo
estadounidense y disfrazando a un
partido que está completamente dominado
por
la izquierda radical prueba de eso es
que en efecto la agenda de pronisa en
verde es la que está sobre el tapete la
agenda del 2016
el hecho de que le den un minuto
la candidata al ministro norteamericano
ocasio el hecho de que quieran presentar
la verdad una careta de moderación no va
a engañar al pueblo porque hay una
realidad que está ocurriendo los eeuu en
las ciudades que están que parece que
son ciudades en afganistán cuando eran
controladas por los talibanes de manera
que ayer no escuchamos ni una palabra
acerca de en efecto los cuerpos
subversivos e ideólogos del marxismo
qué es el movimiento de blackwater y es
una falsa
mensaje un falso mensaje de unión cuando
realidad lo que se busca es fragmentar a
la sociedad en
e identificación es diferente así es
como opera y eso va contrario a la
noción norteamericana de manera de que
más allá de que esta noche pues habrá
esa continuidad hasta que siga hasta el
jueves el pueblo estadounidense no está
engañado y la prueba estará en los
resultados en noviembre bien esa es la
opinión del politólogo julio schilling
él es estratega republicano y vámonos
ahora con una estratega demócrata es
rodolfo por analista político muchas
gracias por estar con nosotros también
estratega a rodolfo por hoy hay una
delegación de 17 representantes
dirigentes el eje
y además de otros grupos como el
movimiento juvenil como buscar el
partido demócrata la obtención de un
mayor apoyo por parte de estos grupos
del electorado
gracias a la invitación saludos todos
los televidentes
el partido demócrata siempre se ha
definido como un partido de carpa am es
capaz de absorber minorías diferencias
convivencias en fin un partido que se
parece más a los estados unidos que lo
que puede ser en cualquier otro partido
lo transmito en que mejor refleja la
instancia de convivir y permitir que
otros vivan a diferencia del partido
republicano que es un partido excluyente
plural pequeño
depende mucho de de aquellos que se
pudieran ser la cara que quiere el
estatuto que ese será mentado verdad
será peritado está cambiando cada día
más al porque para el 2050
tenemos cientos 11 millones
recibe en este país que vienen de países
latinoamericanos
de su entorno
bien pues esa es la opinión de rodolfo
por estrategas demócratas seguiremos por
supuesto con todos los analistas ahora
enlazamos con la corresponsal de france
24 en nuevayork mamen sala mamen vamos a
abordar sobre lo que se viene y es que
las carreras demócratas comenzaron con
un choque de ideas pero ayer si algo
dejó en claro la convención nacional
demócrata es unión hoy veremos más
aristas o podemos esperar también la
misma unidad
hola muy buenas noches yo creo que hoy
vamos a ver la misma unidad ayer nos
centramos más en la parte más política
con estos dos mensajes claros como
decías 1era unidad que la vimos sobre
todo de la mano del ex candidato bernie
sanders y otro era empatía que es lo que
también han estado destacando hacen
figuras dentro del partido demócrata de
su candidato joe biden yo creo que hoy
vamos a ver una parte más personal del
candidato sobre todo que va a llegar de
la mano de su mujer que cerrará esta
segunda noche de convención demócrata y
desde luego vamos a ver unidad porque
ayer desde el punto de vista les
funcionó bastante bien ayer vimos un
evento ágil unido en el que los
demócratas remaban en la misma dirección
y eso pareció funcionar bien entre los
tres potenciales votantes así que hoy
veremos un poquito de lo mismo
bien y en esas imágenes que vemos a tu
espalda y también que ya estamos
compartiendo aquí con ustedes es como
está empezando la convención del día de
hoy que estamos viendo antes del
discurso de apertura un rol que el
across america esto es escuchar a
votantes delegados padres de familia
maestros propietarios de pequeñas
empresas activistas líderes del partido
demócrata mientras emiten sus votos
oficialmente para nominar a joe biden y
convertirse así en la apuesta del
partido demócrata este año
joe biden mamen no quiso seleccionar
sólo a una estrella en ascenso como
normalmente se hace en este tipo de
convenciones sino que pidió a 17
políticos que señal manda a los
demócratas y en general al país
estadounidense
ayer fue muy interesante alan que no
solamente escuchamos voces políticas
también escuchamos voces de ciudadanos y
yo creo que hoy se intenta dar un poco
la misma sensación de que esta
convención va a ser diferente en todos
los sentidos es muy interesante esto que
dices de los 17 participantes veremos a
ver cómo van esos discursos enlazados
uno detrás de otro durante este momento
tenemos que pensar que hoy también se va
a realizar esa votación nominal de
representantes de las 57 delegaciones
estatales y territoriales un acto que
por lo general suele durar unas dos
horas cuando se celebra de manera física
y hoy se va a reducir a 30 minutos para
que no se haga muy pesado con el tema
virtual interesante también escucharemos
durante 60 segundos a la senadora a la
legisladora alejandra alexandre a ocasio
cortes que va a ser también un tema que
ha levantado bastantes entradas a lo
largo del día de hoy por el corto tiempo
que haya andado para participar en ese
minuto va a tener que movilizar a los
jóvenes para que sigan a yo bailé sus
jóvenes que apostaban por ver
sanders y va a tener también que
movilizar el voto de los latinos que en
estos momentos pues también están un
poquito enfadados porque de momento no
se les está dando mucho a mucha voz en
estas en estos dos primeros días de
convención de hecho esta mañana veíamos
al que fuera también un candidato en las
primarias a julián castro apuntar
precisamente a esto y comentar cómo se
está olvidando ligeramente a ese público
latino no debemos olvidar que 32
millones de latinos en este país que ese
año tienen derecho a votar muy bien pues
seguimos hablando de este tema que nos
está identificando mamen sal a las 17
estrellas demócratas en ascenso pero es
momento de irnos con el politólogo julio
chilling estratega republicano les
recuerdo julio la convención nacional
demócrata a lo largo de los años ha
convertido nombres poco conocidos y como
una prueba de ello
barack obama que antes de postularse
para presidente en las elecciones de
2008 pronunció este discurso de apertura
en la convención de 2004 cuando era
senador del estado de illinois este año
el que se haya elegido a 17 consideras
que esto puede ser un acierto o una
falta de liderazgos nuevos en el partido
demócrata pero la realidad es que los
congresos políticos en los eeuu siempre
han servido de punto de lanza para
carreras todos recordamos en el año 64
gran rating
el congreso demócrata puesto realmente
de un discurso estelar como tú bien
mencionaste sadam el ex presidente obama
sin duda pues tuvo una presencia que
impactó y se fue preparando para su
ascenso político sin embargo no vemos
eso ahora porque si fuéramos a mirar en
términos de éxito en cuanto a controlar
julio julio chilling discúlpame te estoy
interrumpiendo porque vamos a escuchar
la salida de la ex procuradora general
interina vamos a regresar contigo
después de su pronunciamiento
de una justicia igualitaria serví como
vicefiscal en la administración de biden
y obama
y estuve por la transición después de
diez días fui despedida por no defender
la prohibición de viajes desde países
musulmanes ese fue el principio de
ataques hacia nuestras instituciones
democráticas y a los servidores públicos
dedicados como yo estos oficiales no
hicieron un juramento hacia una persona
o un partido en estos servidores
públicos prometieron respetar nuestras
leyes y nuestra constitución y trabajar
en nombre del pueblo estadounidense pero
desde el principio que llegó al
presidente con él a utilizado su
posición para beneficiarse a sí mismo en
lugar de nuestro país
él ha pisoteado el estado derecho ha
tratado de crear un arma desde el
departamento de justicia para proteger
sus amigos y atacar a sus enemigos en
lugar de enfrentarse a vladimir putin
siguen a un dictador que aún no quiere
interferir en nuestras elecciones él
está incluso tratando de sabotear
nuestro servicio postal para evitar que
la gente pueda votar
sus ataques constantes al fpv y a la
prensa libre a los instructores
generales a los jueces todo esto tiene
un solo propósito es evitar que se
revise su abuso de poder
y él simplemente trata a nuestro país
como si fuera su negocio familiar esta
vez llevar a nuestro a la bancarrota
moral a este país pero nuestro país no
le pertenece a ella nos pertenece a
todos nosotros
joe biden entiende esto y el han pasado
toda su vida poniendo a nuestro país
primero él nunca se ha echado para atrás
ante un reto o un bullying él ha visto
lo mejor de nosotros y vive según los
principios que nos definen como
estadounidenses el servicio la
integridad
el coraje la compasión incontables
historias de joe biden yendo a buscar a
alguien en su momento de necesidad es
bueno este es el momento de necesidad
del país necesitamos un presidente que
respete las leyes y el privilegio del
servicio público
que refleje nuestros valores que le
importen nuestra gente necesitamos un
presidente que vaya a restaurar el alma
de eeuu necesitamos a joe biden
es esa ley la exprocuradora general
interina que básicamente se refirió a
tres ejes en su discurso crítico la
presidencia de donald trump habló sobre
rusia que precisamente hoy el comité de
inteligencia del senado liderado por los
republicanos concluyó que rusia utilizó
a aliados del presidente trump para
tratar de interferir en las elecciones
de 2016 y también habló sobre joe biden
ella dijo los servidores públicos
prometen defender nuestra constitución
cumplir nuestras leyes y trabajar en
nombre del pueblo estadounidense pero
desde el momento en que el presidente
trampa asumió el cargo ha utilizado su
cargo para beneficiarse a sí mismo y no
a eeuu ha pisoteado el estado de derecho
tratando de convertir el departamento de
justicia en un arma para atacar a sus
enemigos y proteger a sus amigos
concluyó nuevamente diciendo que
necesitan un presidente hablando de los
estadounidenses que puedan respetar las
leyes y que sea un privilegio servir al
público entonces retomó con el
politólogo estratega republicano del
partido del presidente de donald trump
julio schilling julio si quieres
terminar
tu participación anterior
bueno me están informando que tenemos
primero a comer el senador de nueva york
vamos a escuchar lo que recibió a
inmigrantes como mis abuelos y un
símbolo de la libertad y un icono de
esperanza para el mundo
28 ha dividido a nuestro país ha
disminuido nuestra grandeza y todo lo
que representa esta estatua de atrás
mismo incluso se escondió en un búnker y
mientras que golpeaban y manifestantes
170 mil personas han muerto por kobe y
dicen que esto es lo que es un
presidente nunca debería decir algo así
el presidente lincoln honrando los
grandes sacrificios de caris bolt que no
dijo es lo que es el presidente
roosevelt yendo a un tercio de la nación
en problemas no dijo esto es lo que es
eeuu donald trump
no les ha cumplido necesitamos un
presidente con integridad y con
experiencia para liberarnos y sacarnos
de la crisis es un hombre con una mano
firme y con un corazón grande que nunca
vaya a
en cumplirle eeuu esa persona es yo vaya
será un gran presidente pero si vamos a
ganar esta batalla por la por el alma de
esta nación no puede hacerlo solo los
demócratas deben retomar el senado vamos
a mantenernos unidos desde sanders y
moore
mancini warner y con nuestra unidad
vamos a llevar un cambio audaz y
dramático a ese país
les diré algo de las cosas que haremos
con el presidente vaivén y la
vicepresidenta harris y una mayoría
demócrata haremos que la salud sea
asequible para todos acabaremos con la
inequidad de los salarios que ha plagado
tanto a este país desde hace tanto
tiempo si tomaremos acción decisiva para
combatir el cambio climático y salvar el
planeta vamos a proteger los derechos de
votaciones en luchar contra
racismo sistémico y vamos a restaurar
una corte suprema que busque apoyar a la
gente y no las corporaciones vamos a
reconstruir nuestra infraestructura y
asegurarnos que cada hogar desde las
ciudades hasta eeuu rural sea restaurada
salvaremos el servicio postal de una vez
por todas y vamos a derrotar al kobe 19
esta enfermedad y según esta estatua
detrás mío vamos a reformar nuestros
sistemas de inmigración para que los
inmigrantes que quieren ser libres
finalmente puedan convertirse en
ciudadanos juntos vamos a darle nueva
vida a esas esperanzas
a aquellos que vieron a esta gran mujer
con su torta sabiendo que podían
construir una mejor vida aquí en este
país y después de esta gran pesadilla
eeuu finalmente se despertará lucha un
futuro más brillante y un nuevo día
escuchamos al senador chuck schumer de
nueva york uno de los principales
opositores a la presidencia de donald
trump y quien junto con la presidenta de
la cámara de representantes nancy pelosi
está en una batalla contra el gobierno
de trump por las medidas contra el
coronavirus y también por la
financiación del servicio postal sal y
jets quien habló anteriormente la ex
procuradora general interina fue
despedida por el presidente de donald
trump en 2017 pues podemos ir ahora sí
con el politólogo julio healing julio
nos estabas mencionando el punto de la
convención nacional demócrata si quieres
terminar tu idea o si quieres retomar
algo de lo que ya dijeron los dos
primeros participantes en la convención
del día de hoy como no voy a hablar
rápido salí gates hay que ver hay que
tener una cara de palo porque acaba de
admitir el bajo juramento de que ella
ella fue cómplice en la investigación
ilegal de ciudadanos norteamericanos
donde se falsificó documentación para
espiar la campaña
del presidente de trump y dijo que si
ella hubiera tenido la información que
ahora tenemos pues no lo hubiera
autorizado él presentó obama violó la
ley quebró el estado de derecho fue el
primer presidente en utilizar el fbi y
la cia para perseguir a sus enemigos
políticos ellos sin precedentes se está
investigando y quiera dios que se aplica
la justicia porque probablemente van a
ir personas a la cárcel por violar los
derechos de los estadounidenses en
cuanto a shocks
summers efe el ellos en el partido
demócrata estaba cuando el presidente
trump después de tener sólo seis
personas con contagio el coronavirus
cerró los vuelos con china
el partido demócrata estaba más
interesado en tener la audiencia de
porque lo había tenido porque lo
consideraba racista y en tratar de
efectuar un golpe constitucional
mezclándolo con él
con los rusos con ucranianos que no
tienen nada que ver la evidencia
demostró era totalmente falso entonces
es realmente lo que hemos visto en el
primer momento es un intento de sacar
este presidente de la de la de la casa
blanca pero el pueblo del repito
estadounidense entiende bien los hechos
y hay que entender qué
y la cantidad de muertos que hay en gran
medida por la negligencia del partido
demócrata que un mes después que el
presidente cerró los vuelos en el
sicólogo si estaba invitando a las
personas a ir al barrio chino de san
francisco a abrazar a las personas igual
que el alcalde de nueva york en el
barrio chino de nueva york en otras
palabras ellos menospreciaron llamaron
sí pero juego al presidente y cuando
quitó los vuelos a europa lo mismo sin
embargo eso demostró salvar vidas y
antes de hablar con los otros analistas
uno de ellos de estratega demócrata
vámonos con nuestro corresponsal de
france 24 en los ángeles ja que no hemos
escuchado mauricio cárdenas mauricio
gracias por acompañarnos el presidente
está realizando giras hoy por ejemplo en
arizona entre otras zonas son trata de
socavar la atención hacia los demócratas
y también ha dicho que su convención era
una siestecita incluso antes de que
empezara esta opinión merece los eventos
de trump que se realicen en esta fecha
algo lo decíamos al inicio de la
especial inusual y además bajo
de la crisis de el coronavirus
así es a la saludo para todos ustedes
desde la ciudad de los ángeles bueno es
algo poco tradicional porque la historia
de la política en los eeuu indicaba que
cuando se hace la convención de un
partido en este caso la demócrata pues
la convención republicana y los
seguidores y políticos republicanos
guardaban una distancia prudente para no
entrometerse mientras sucedía la
convención de sus enemigos políticos en
este caso trump que ha ido contra la
corriente en todo lo que estaba
preestablecido en este país pues hace un
viaje a la costa oeste para tratar de
atraer las miradas hacia su viaje y
quitarle un poco de interés a la
convención demócrata ha venido a la
costa oeste donde no tiene muchos
partidarios donde la mayoría de los
estados son demócratas incluyendo por
oregón por la nevada por california y ha
venido tratando de hacer eso no era algo
que realmente los medios de comunicación
no le han puesto
cuidado y que simplemente se ve que es
como una maniobra de distracción y más
con lo que tú dices que era como una
siestecita pues me parece que pinta muy
a las claras lo que ha sido la
personalidad del presidente que tenemos
se interrumpió
mauricio discúlpame que te que está
interrumpiendo es momento de que
escuchemos al ex presidente bill clinton
millones de empleos en el país cómo ha
respondido primero dijo que el virus
está bajo control y que iba a
desaparecer por hombre cuando no fue así
que estuvo en televisión todos los días
hablando del gran trabajo que
supuestamente si es cuando los
científicos nos querían dar información
vital cuando necesitábamos a los
expertos en los ignoró solamente cuando
explotó el cob y demás estado se le
pidió a la gente que usara mascarillas y
aún así miles de maurienne
cuando le preguntaban y él decía
simplemente es lo que es
pero tenía que ser así realmente no
el cob y nos golpeó mucho más duro de
los nervios somos cuatro por ciento de
la población mundial 0 25 por ciento de
los casos de kobe nuestra tasa de
desempleo es de 2 veces más que la del
reino unido más de tres veces que la de
japón donde dice que estamos liderando
el mundo bueno si usamos la única
economía industrial que tiene una tasa
de desempleo triplicado en tiempos así
la oficina web debería ser un centro de
comando es todo bien lugar es un centro
de tormentas solamente hay caos una cosa
que nunca cambia es su determinación
ante evitar la responsabilidad y culpar
a otros nunca asume la responsabilidad
ustedes tienen que decidir si quieren
reanudar su contrato o dárselo a alguien
más si quieren un presidente que defina
el trabajo como horas al día viendo
televisión y pasando su tiempo en las
redes sociales él es su hombre
y si están tratando de entretener o de
reclamar pero en una crisis se cae como
una casa de cartas y el gobierno
responde a eso para acabar con él hay
que enfrentarse a los hechos nuestro
partido ha estado unido y está
ofreciendo una opción muy diferente muy
diferente una persona que irá a trabajar
una persona que tiene los pies en la
tierra y que irá a trabajar una persona
que tomará la responsabilidad que se va
a concentrar que va a unir y no a
dividir nuestra opción
nos ayudó a salir de una recesión antes
y puede hacerlo de nuevo
en 2009 obama y biden comenzaron con la
peor economía desde la gran depresión y
cuando acabaron se entregaron más de
seis años consecutivos de crecimiento en
los empleos el aceptó la responsabilidad
por la ley de recuperación crearon
millones de empleos y comenzaron nuevas
compañías en comunidades en todo el país
ahora él está comprometido a reconstruir
el país como
bueno tiene un plan detallado
inteligente para invertir en áreas
vitales para el futuro e verify en las
finanzas para los pequeños negocios en
el planeta para combatir el cambio
climático una infraestructura moderna
que traiga al país la conectividad y las
inversiones que otros dan por sentados y
asegurarse que los afroamericanos los
nativos las mujeres los inmigrantes y
otras comunidades que se han quedado
atrás sean partícipes de esta economía y
de nuestra sociedad
iovine quiere construir una economía
mucho mejor para este mundo cambiante
mejor para los jóvenes mejor para las
familias que trabajan y cuidan a sus
hijos para aquellos que han perdido sus
empleos y necesitan nuevos para aquellos
que quieren dejar de ser un daño
colateral de las tierras comerciales y
también para las personas enfermas y con
discapacidades mejor por un mejor
salario y con un acceso a educación y
salud incluyendo las drogas los
medicamentos por prescripción y también
el retiro seguro y también la salida
para gas él no simplemente va a poner su
firma en un cheque y se los hará llegar
pero diciendo que viene de él él va a
reflejar esa contribución en esta
economía creciente y la diferencia es
total ustedes saben lo que haría
donación con otros cuatro años estarían
repartiendo culpas y lo quería
reconstruir el país nosotros contra
ellos todos vivimos y trabajamos juntos
en este país es una opción clara el
futuro de nuestro país está ahí muchas
gracias el ex presidente bill clinton
escuchamos él definió el kobe 19 y sus
impactos económicos en eeuu satirizó por
ejemplo en que donald trump presume de
ser el primero en el mundo pero él dice
que se en cifras negativas como se tener
el doble de la tasa de desempleo que
reinó unido- enfatizó en que en un
momento como éste la oficina oval
debería ser un centro de mando pero que
es un centro de tormentas donde solo hay
caos y que sólo hay una cosa que nunca
cambia la determinación de trump de
negar la responsabilidad y echar la
culpa también especificó mencionó un
plan detallado financiero otro plan en
cambio climático y sanitario de el
partido demócrata y de joe biden en
específico dijo que está unido para
ofrecerles una opción muy diferente a un
presidente listo para trabajar un tipo
con los pies en la tierra así identifico
y que hace el trabajo con una misión
asumí la responsabilidad y no echar la
culpa como lo hace donald trump regresó
con mauricio cárdenas a quien le pidió
igual una disculpa ya todos los
colaboradores de esta emisión especial
ya lo saben es así el imprevisto que nos
tiene esta convención tú estaba cerrando
el tema de la gira que está realizando
como contra gira demócrata donald trump
pero si quieres mencionar algo del ex
presidente bill clinton vaya pues fue el
primer presidente demócrata en seis
décadas en ser reelegido dos veces te
escuchamos mauricio
si ha sido una constante en las últimas
presidencia de los eeuu en los
demócratas y republicanos el ser
reelegidos en este caso creo que la que
está más en riesgo es la de toro macho
porque ha sido una presidencia muy
polémica aunque como lo digo yo mi
programa de radio
económicamente venía muy bien y haciendo
un buen trabajo el presidente de tron y
ahora me parece su mayor patrimonio para
la reelección justamente le cae esta
pandemia que echa abajo la economía y
web ya sabemos todo lo que ha pasado por
eso está en la cuerda floja creo yo su
reelección y por eso miren tan fuerte
los demócratas aunque con un candidato
que tal vez no era el ideal pero yo
vaivén es la representación de los obama
en la casa blanca y creo que ese es su
mayor
ventaja en las urnas entonces
trump trata por todos los medios de
robarse la atención con esta gira que
estábamos comentando está haciendo por
la costa oeste del país y trata de
hacerlo también con los estímulos
económicos por eso quiere pasarse
por encima del congreso para dar el
estímulo de desempleo que primero eran
400 luego no eran 400 ahora parece que
son 300 con 100 dólares que va a poner
cada estado y ahora también quiere
pasarse a demócratas y republicanos que
no se ponen de acuerdo con un nuevo
cheque de estímulo de 1200 para padres
de familia que han hecho los impuestos y
para 500 dólares para los dependientes
en esa declaración de impuestos entonces
es una guerra política es una campaña
presidencial como nunca antes hemos
visto en la historia de los eeuu a ver
bien pues ese es mauricio cárdenas
corresponsal de france 24 en los ángeles
y ahora vamos a hablar precisamente de
las reacciones de esta convención por
parte de donald trump por ejemplo dijo
que el discurso de ayer de michelle
obama fue extremadamente divisivo
criticó el no haber incluido en su
discurso a kamala harris esto habrá sido
por olvido o porque no incluyó a
deliberadamente obama a esta candidata
vicepresidenta para el partido demócrata
vamos a hacerle esta pregunta a rafael
piñero es el profesor de relaciones
internacionales precisamente justo
cuando terminó de hablar bill clinton el
ex presidente de eeuu cuyo tema fuerte
sería pues las consecuencias económicas
favorables que dejó en eeuu te
escuchamos rafael
no estoy escuchando
rafael me escuchas
y perdimos la comunicación con rafael
piñero e intentaremos establecer la
nueva mente entonces le dirijo esta
misma pregunta a la estratega demócrata
l rodolfo por rodolfo estoy haciendo dos
preguntas pero básicamente me se unen
con las críticas que hace donald trump a
los demócratas en específico a la
presidencia de obama que está criticando
por ejemplo lo que ayer dijo michelle
que pues vaya dijo que gracias a la
administración obama él está como
presidente de eeuu y también a bill
clinton pues él era criticado no sólo
por trump sino por muchos que envuelven
el movimiento mitú por participar en
esta convención
sin palabras del presidente son paran de
esperarse sus referencias siempre son
las mismas y son parte de sí si quiere
la caja de resonancia en la que viven
todos los simpatizantes todo regresa a
luchar de la culpa para para buscar
cosas que pasaron en el 94 con clinton
en fin no tiene una estructura del
discurso que pudiste decir que alimente
interrumpo vamos a escuchar para muchos
a la estrella del día alexandra ocasio
cortes la congresista
este gran movimiento de personas que
están trabajando para crear derechos
económicos del siglo 21 incluyendo la
salud garantizada mejor educación
mejores salarios y derechos laborales
para todos en eeuu un movimiento que
está luchando por reconocer y reparar
las heridas de la injusticia racial de
la colonización de la misoginia y la
homofobia y proponer y construir e
imaginar sistemas de inmigración y de
política exterior que eviten la
xenofobia y la violencia del pasado un
movimiento que se dé cuenta de la
brutalidad insostenible de una economía
que premia las grandes diferencias de
riqueza para algunos a expensas de la
estabilidad para muchos y que organiza
aquí una campaña de bases para retomar
nuestra democracia en un momento cuando
millones de personas en eeuu están
buscando
sin soluciones sistémicas
al desempleo a la falta de salud del
pueblo
y por el de todos para presidente de
estados unidos de américa
aquí
bueno pues ella es la congresista
alexandría ocasio cortes de nueva york
una de las integrantes más destacadas
del ala progresista del partido
demócrata y con un pequeño papel en esta
convención algo que igual ha sido
polémico precisamente te lo quiero
preguntar rodolfo pop porque sólo un
minuto de participación de la
descendiente de puerto rico de padres de
puerto rico y también si quieres tú
cerrar tu idea anterior te escuchamos al
estratega demócrata
si lo que me refería anteriormente de la
caja de resonancia en la que viven los
republicanos y como sus temas luego
terminan por evolucionar en el mismo
discurso desde los años 60 cuando
subieron el concepto de conservador
conservatismo de una forma que solo sea
al inicio de la creación de los estados
unidos y buscaron entonces en los
latinoamericanos y las minorías algún
tipo de referencias y aquellos que
habían sufrido se quiere
es un pasado
simpatiza asimismo el partido dijo
al igual que antes
bien pues bueno también tenemos un poco
de problemas de comunicación por eso te
interrumpo rodolfo pero seguimos
hablando de la congresista de nueva
york- alexandría ocasio cortes tiene
mucho las miradas puestas en la
legisladora precisamente por el margen
el gran grupo de electores que podría
ella tener para el demócrata y vamos
precisamente con la corresponsal de
france 24 en nueva york de donde es
congresista alexandre ocasio cortes va a
pensar la que resalta del discurso de
alexandra ocasión
pues ha sido muy interesante alan ver
ese discurso más sosegado y más
tranquilo de lo que nos tiene
acostumbrados normalmente cuando sus
discursos son en directo entonces es
interesante ver el efecto que tiene el
pre grabado ha sido muy poquito tiempo
ha sido solamente 60 segundos pero yo
creo que haya dejado muy claro a lo que
venía a defender a bernie sanders
acabando su discurso pronunciando alto y
claro su nombre y ha intentado pues en
ese poquito tiempo que se le ha dejado a
atraer la atención de este público
hispano que ya decíamos que se encuentra
un poquito de momento triste porque no
se les ha dado tanto espacio como ellos
esperaban y por supuesto a movilizar al
ala más izquierdista del partido a esos
seguidores de bernie sanders que tienen
también que aceptar ahora a iowa y dell
pero ha sido es muy interesante alan el
efecto que tiene el pre grabado de su
discurso que no tiene nada que ver con
la alexandre ocasio cortes que estamos
acostumbrados a ver en televisión
muchas gracias mamen vámonos ahora con
rafael piñero me identifican que ya está
bien la comunicación con el profesor de
relaciones internacionales y es momento
de hablar precisamente de esas
divisiones políticas que pues vaya la
mayoría de demócratas pero más allá se
está identificando políticamente en eeuu
y es que en esta delegación en esta
convención perdón habrá más delegados el
jefe y el jefe te cv en esta convención
que en cualquier otra incluida una
cantidad histórica de delegados trans
además de veteranos y activistas cuál
será el resultado político de esta
jornada
yo creo que sigue estando por verse la
estrategia del partido demócrata en ese
sentido ha sido crear una gran coalición
una gran coalición que permita una
convergencia alrededor de un programa en
este caso muy de centro con una
influencia significativa de ese ala o
esa la más inclinada hacia la izquierda
de bernie sanders y alexandra ocasión
cortes estará por verse yo creo que la
elección que hizo joe biden trata de
solidificar esa posición de candidato de
centro joe biden siempre ha sido amigo
de el pueblo en general y muy enfocado
en los temas que para el público
americano son son radicales pero al
mismo tiempo tampoco lo suficientemente
conservador especialmente en temas de
política exterior yo creo que la palabra
más repetida de alexandra casio cortes
hoy fue hacer una gran coalición y ese
es el objetivo y también lo decía ayer
michelle obama
porque lo van a seguir repitiendo y es
este presidente no tiene ni la capacidad
moral ética para dirigir esta nación y
por ello necesitamos un cambio esa es la
concentración y el centro uno de los
ejes principales del partido demócrata
para el día de hoy bien muchas gracias
rafael piñero os vamos a escuchar ahora
a rodolfo powell estratega demócrata
precisamente para que nos identifique
desde su opinión esta división política
que tiene y que está pasando en eeuu si
desde tu perspectiva está la
radicalización de algunos grupos que
estaría beneficiando ya sea igual a la
demócrata o al mismo donald trump rumbo
a la presidencia ahorita precisamente
está pensando en la convención imágenes
de grupos minoritarios y ya habló la
congresista lisa blount de delaware que
es copresidente de la campaña de baile
si en lo referente a estos grupos que
son titulado como extremistas
en parte de la retórica cuando las
minorías se expresan sobre entrevistas
cuanto dos las grandes masas
quieren controlar duración el programa
georgia los santos amores estos empresas
por ejemplo
tú eres el ejemplo más es más en si
habláis smartbird y quieren echar la
culpa de todo aquellas personas en plan
de negocios arropar durante la perito de
tan física sin embargo cuando hay una
persona es asesinada o puerta
nada de eso
sí
si rodolfo nuevamente interrumpo pero
ahora es porque nuevamente estamos
teniendo problemas en la comunicación
contigo momento de que vayamos con el
estratega republicano a hacerle su
recuento de lo que se ha dicho hasta el
momento por parte de los demócratas y
también si te parece bien julio chilling
es que sí es cierto que estas divisiones
lo dicen los demócratas no las creo
trump pero si las ha explotado y las ha
utilizado políticamente
alan y la narrativa la falsa narrativa
que quieren promover es consistente con
la teoría crítica que viene del marxismo
o sea de la victimización es un arma que
el marxismo cultural emplea para llegar
al poder primero categóricamente se
puede decir yo reto cualquiera que me dé
prueba de que los eeuu a isis el racismo
sistémico eso es mentira no hay racismo
sistémico y quien quiere tener un debate
acerca de eso puede darle la bienvenida
y ojalá que el tiempo alcanzará pero es
la narrativa que tiene que haber la
diputada ocasión me parece bastante
sincera cuando está hablando de una
programación sistémica o sea me parece
probablemente la persona más honesta que
va a hablar en todo estos cuatro días
porque ella sí es clara en sus objetivos
o sea promover una revolución socialista
en este país y placa mater
hay que ser realmente osea fanatizado o
muy bruto para no entender que black
light matters se basa en el marxismo que
abraza la noción de la ideología de
género que es una lleva a cabo una
guerra contra la familia tradicional con
los valores judeocristianos de eso
estamos hablando entonces el partido
demócrata está en manos de individuos
que abrazan esta noción y volviendo a la
referencia el querer legitimar una
organización marxista que se ha robado
el tema de racismo racismo es mal el
racismo hay que combatirlo pero una cosa
es racismo y otra cosa es racismo
sistémico entonces esto le ha venido
como anillo al dedo a los que están
encabezando el partido demócrata y vayan
más bien no tienen nada que ver en esto
se abren los está siendo instrumentado
él básicamente será un pelele
en todo este movimiento pero repito la
sociedad estadounidense lo tiene claro
ellos están padeciendo y no solo en esa
sociedad incluyo a los negros
norteamericanos que están viendo sus
vidas en peligro porque no hay policía
porque no hay determinado respeto al
orden y la institución de un estado de
derecho y eso es lo que están hablando
no hemos visto ni una defensa del gran
trabajo que hacen las fuerzas burguesas
o los eeuu ninguna todo es alimentar la
narrativa de la victimización porque si
insisten no han aprendido nada del 2016
siguen insistiendo que esa es la clave
para la victoria pero lo dicen no es
porque estén impresionado en el fracaso
sino porque ideológicamente están
apegados a la teoría crítica ok y la
teoría crítica es lo que explica la
narrativa que el partido demócrata está
siguiendo vayan a la página
y ahí van a entender bien de qué se
trata
chris sanders no tiene que estar
recibiendo el premio su plataforma si en
efecto ha ganado bien pues muchas
gracias al estratega republicano y
vámonos ahora hasta washington la
capital estadounidense porque lo
decíamos alexandra ocasio cortes es
quien tenía mucho las miradas en su
discurso del día de hoy y ya se están
generando reacciones al voto que propuso
ella en su discurso precisamente dijo
bernie sanders no joe biden lo que
mencionaba la legisladora y es por ello
que le pregunto a diana castañeda por
qué lo hizo que está pasando en la
convención en este momento si nos
pudieras detallar un poquito más lo que
algunos incluso señalaban por adelantado
así en lo que estamos viendo ahora es el
inicio de este proceso tradicional
conocido como rouco en donde se comienza
a llamar estado por estado para saber en
este conteo nacional de delegados cuál
es el apoyo para el candidato en
específico y aunque el partido demócrata
ha centrado esta convención en yo bailé
recordemos que bernie sanders prefirió
también estar en este conteo permanecer
en los tarjetones de las primarias
aunque anunciara su retiro de manera
anticipada para poder negociar esa
plataforma que tendrá el partido
demócrata durante estos comicios y
después de que sea elegido el candidato
oficial entonces esto le daría mayor el
poder de negociación y claro lo que
estamos viendo es
una división de quienes apoyan a vader y
a sanders porque precisamente ese es uno
de los retos uno de los varios retos que
tiene el partido demócrata ya que como
hemos visto también se ha centrado
muchísimo esta convención en las figuras
más importantes en el a la más
tradicional demócrata que son los
clinton también se encuentran en los
kennedy y son representan digamos esa a
la más poderosa de los demócratas porque
en unas elecciones no sólo se necesita
tener una buena plataforma sino
capacidad de recaudar fondos de
mantenerse en una campaña presidencial
por eso es que hemos visto también como
la convención ha tratado de darle más
participación a figuras locales y
estatales del partido demócrata y
también como pues tendrá que enfrentar
otros retos como el que las personas o
muchos electores no salgan a votar o no
voten
a través de correo debido a la pandemia
por temor a la seguridad pero también a
la estrategia del presidente de donald
trump de desprestigio del sistema
electoral en los eeuu también tendrán
que hacer frente a cómo lo mencionábamos
ese apoyo que tienen los más
progresistas que está que estábamos
viendo en el discurso de ocasión cortes
pidiendo específicas medidas en esta
agenda como incrementar el salario
mínimo a los trabajadores que haya
educación para todos en los eeuu de
manera gratuita y acceso al sistema de
salud esas políticas y esas peticiones
que está haciendo sanders y que están
haciendo también los más progresistas
dentro del partido se van a estar
negociando dentro de esta convención y
de hecho
sanders y bailén se reunieron antes de
que sanders le diera oficialmente
hace unos meses atrás el apoyo
joe biden así que esto lo que está
ocurriendo ahora y de manera simbólica
vimos también cómo le dio el apoyo a
bailén una vigilante que se encontró con
él en el ascensor y que decidió
convertirse como ya lo decía en amiga de
bailén porque le gustaba su plataforma y
ella salió dándole también el apoyo un
apoyo simbólico al candidato vaya bien
pues hablando específicamente alexandría
cortes dando su voto de confianza como
bien nos identifica diana castañeda con
nuestra corresponsal en washington con
quien estaremos por supuesto en el
transcurso de este especial y vámonos
ahora con nuestra corresponsal de france
24 en nueva york' y es que para ir
saliendo del tema de divisiones
políticas e ir entrando al tema de la
crisis sanitaria que ha generado la
pandemia del coronavirus en eeuu es que
hay un contexto en el que los latinos y
los afroamericanos son los grupos que
han sido más impactados en eeuu por
parte del coronavirus
mamen porque se debe esta situación a
que se le atribuye que sean estos grupos
los más vulnerables y como se va a
manejar políticamente
sí bueno claro por supuesto es una
información que hemos ido viendo a lo
largo de toda esta pandemia como las
minorías afroamericanas y latinas han
sido las más castigadas por este
coronavirus por un tema de la complexión
física por un tema de que al final
ocupan los puestos en esos trabajos
esenciales gracias a los cuales el país
no se ha cerrado completamente a la
población latina aquí en eeuu y
afroamericana ha sido la que ha
mantenido esos negocios mínimos a flote
cuando todo lo demás estaba cerrado con
lo cual pues es de entender que hayan
sido los más castigados por esta
pandemia y éste sin duda ha sido un
punto crucial y que vamos a escuchar
mucho durante los próximos días de
convención porque sobre todo el
principal arma de ataque a donald trump
por parte de los demócratas y por parte
de una gran población dentro de eeuu de
hecho el coronavirus ha sido también uno
de los puntos importantes que ha tratado
el ex presidente bill clinton en su
discurso un discurso que para mí ha sido
a digamos que hacía tiempo que no lo
veíamos
a atacar de una manera tan clara y tan
incisiva al presidente
donald trump ha sido muy claro y bueno y
esto es y ha sido y esa claridad también
ha sido por el momento en el que estamos
viviendo por esta pandemia en la que nos
encontramos y por esta gestión que ha
hecho el presidente donald trump de la
situación entonces el coronavirus sin
duda va a ser un punto central en los
próximos días de convención y va a ser
desde luego una arma arrojadiza sin
ninguna duda para todos los oradores que
vayamos escuchando muy bien mamen sala
pues precisamente nueva york donde más
se identifica pues esta dolencia que
tienen los grupos de afroamericanos y
también de latinos en la capital
estadounidense y vámonos ahora
nuevamente con rafael piñero es el
profesor de relaciones internacionales
la pregunta específica es qué tan
posible es de realizar los objetivos que
hemos escuchado a lo largo de este día y
también del día de ayer los objetivos
demócratas en temas sanitarias y en
temas económicos por ejemplo la
afiliación a sindicatos lo sé
detención de inmigrantes frenar el culto
a blancos nacionalistas el ataque a las
mujeres que tan posible es llevar a cabo
estos temas que buscan minimizar la
polarización que tiene eeuu
sin duda alguna la polarización se
convierte en el elemento que más divide
hoy a demócratas y republicanos se
perdió lo que los años 90 se llamaban
esos acuerdos nacionales en la medida en
que tanto republicanos como demócratas
se ponían de acuerdo para sacar adelante
algún tipo de legislación en particular
yo pienso que el ala más radical de el
partido republicano que es normal que en
cualquier que de la del partido
demócrata perdón yo creo que es normal
que en cualquier partido o aglomeración
política haya divisiones eso hace parte
del juego democrático a cabo una una
lógica que se vio truncada por el
coronavirus y en ese sentido no tuvieron
la posibilidad de seguir debatiendo a lo
largo y ancho del país el resultado es
que yo va a ir en ganó el resultado es
que el giro extremo que buscaba y en
bernie sanders y algunos otros que lo
que lo seguían no podrá ser ahora hay
que encontrar ese terreno en el cual sin
acceder a todas y cada una de las
demandas o sin acceder a la hoja de ruta
que buscaba impulsar el bernie sanders
joe biden se sienta cómodo se sienta
tranquilo impulsando esa idea en estados
que particularmente son difíciles ya
sabemos que los demócratas van a votar
mayoritariamente en estados como
california como nueva york y muchos
otros que históricamente votan demócrata
a favor de su candidato el punto es que
no he visto en esta convención personas
que traten de vincular ideas en aquellos
estados que van a ser particularmente
difíciles particularmente como de
indiana como wisconsin como ohio yo creo
que ahí se observa una clásica
convención demócrata en ese sentido los
pesos pesados del partido los pesos
históricos
aquellos que generan atracción y en
menor medida personajes como alexandra o
cayo cortes de tal forma que hay un
espacio que todavía tienen que llenar y
ojalá lo puedan aprovechar de una mejor
manera tengo entendido que en la noche
del día de hoy también iba a participar
con el impago que sin duda alguna
todavía tiene algún tipo de rédito
político dentro
republicano y puede ser como de este
grupo de personas que republicanos con
byd en que sucederá la semana siguiente
cuando el presidente donald trump haga
lo propio en la convención del partido
republicano pues yo creo que ahí sí se
ha notado como una falta de decisión y
de personas claves estratégicas de esos
estados que irán a ser competitivos en
la elección del 3 de noviembre gracias
profesor piñeros estaremos ahí
pendientes con ustedes para retomar
todavía nos falta escuchar a varios
demócratas figuras del día de hoy como
el baile en la esposa de yo bailé en el
candidato bueno
la apuesta demócrata para derrotar a
donald trump en noviembre y momento de
ir con el estratega republicano julio
chilling el politólogo le preguntó
precisamente de estas divisiones que nos
estaba identificando rafael piñero es
nuestro analista anterior si la
comunidad afroamericana que en su
mayoría está con joe biden precisamente
porque rechazan la respuesta de la
presidencia de donald trump al
movimiento black lips mother por ejemplo
de la muerte del ciudadano afroamericano
george floyd como actuó la casa blanca
hay evidencias de que los afroamericanos
se han visto afectados incluso de manera
desproporcionada como no lo han dicho
nuestras corresponsales en eeuu todos
estos factores va a jugarle en contra a
donald trump como le va a ser el
presidente estadounidense pues para
atraer el voto de los enojados por estas
acciones
pero primero es un error
a considerar que los negros
estadounidenses están en contra de
donald trump y que los negros
estadounidenses apoyan al grupo
terrorista no hay que temer eso es un
error
este presidente ha llevado la economía
que quien más ha salido beneficiado ha
sido las minorías los estadounidenses
negros
los estadounidenses e hispanos
entonces eso hay que entenderlo si
miramos las cifras que te refieres del
coronavirus eso es cierto pero el querer
cómo quiere hacer la narrativa de la
izquierda radical y el partido demócrata
de que esto es parte una manifestación
de racismo sistémico es una emoción
absurda es cierto que la disparidad que
hay es producto si queremos entrar en
ese debate precisamente una política
fallida que tiene su origen en la década
de los 60 con el estado de bienestar
social que ha destruido la familia negra
el 75 por ciento de los niños negros que
nacen nacen
con un padre ausente un padre que jamás
se va a ocupar de ello eso es en gran
medida culpa de una política de estado
con la mejor intención que podía haber
tenido pero lo que ha hecho es destruir
a la familia negra entonces todas las
estadísticas toda la evidencia empírica
nos demuestra que niños que crecen en un
hogar con un padre ausente con madres
que es en gran media son adolescentes
pues tienen mucha más probabilidad de
crecer en el crimen la política del
partido demócrata ha sido de en efecto
tener precisamente a los negros
estadounidenses en una casta de miseria
para tener un bloque de voto seguro
entonces hay muchos estadounidenses
afrodescendientes que han visto la
realidad de como su situación ha
mejorado bajo esta administración porque
eso es realmente la noción de la
igualdad no de tratar con migajas a una
clase para que sea un voto
y eso ahora y lo estamos viendo donde
los ciudadanos estadounidenses y no sólo
los negros estadounidenses los hispanos
también la mitad de los policías en la
frontera sur los agentes de la frontera
son hispanos la mitad y han endulzado al
presidente ekström es una falacia
a considerar que el voto hispano va a
ser un voto bloque igual que el voto
negro va a ser un voto bloque por el el
ex candidato es by de eso no se va a
realizar recuerden que los eeuu tiene un
sistema voluntario de voto no es
obligatorio y el entusiasmo que genera
tanto el señor vice como la plataforma
del partido demócrata no no no no
refleja nada el último la última persona
que habló antes que yo dijo algo es
cierto y dijo que en efecto no hay
ningún mensaje de programación que no lo
es como lo escuchado bueno no lo
escuchaba porque no existe el partido
demócrata se basa en la victimización y
en culpar de todo al presidente de trump
de todo si se encuentra la cura si el
presente de trump encuentra la cura de
lo que sea no sólo van manera lo
contrario o sea todo lo que dice van a
ir a lo contrario esa es la realidad
entonces pues es una campaña muy pobre
muy pésima que el único
y narrativa es el odio a el hombre
naranja eso en efecto lo que es y no ha
comprendido nada repito del 2016 esta
vista esta elección la va a ganar en un
porcentaje es mucho más grande bien el
presidente trump bien gracias julio
chilling por supuesto seguimos contigo
el recordamos estratega republicano del
partido del presidente de donald trump
vamos a escuchar más adelante por
supuesto al estratega demócrata rodolfo
pero tenemos problemas de comunicación
se los vamos a tener no se preocupen
momento de ir con mauricio cárdenas y es
que el politólogo julio chilling el
estratega republicano identifico esas
dos palabras que se han mencionado el
día de hoy varias veces racismo
sistémico lo mencionaba no sólo julio
chilling por supuesto y en la convención
lo han mencionado shock sommer por
ejemplo el senador de nueva york
mauricio cárdenas es culpa del racismo
sistémico que por ejemplo las minorías
como los afroamericanos o los
latinoamericanos estén siendo más
castigados por el coronavirus en eeuu
para eso hay varias teorías alan por
ejemplo aquí en california
tenemos un 54% de las víctimas de el
coronavirus son hispanos un número
altísimo es decir somos una minoría pero
ponemos más de la mitad de los contagios
en esta pandemia en gran parte no se
debe al racismo se debe a que el hispano
es el trabajador es el inmigrante que
hace muchos trabajos que los nativos no
hacen y de ahí las consecuencias también
un poco el tema cultural donde no nos
cuidamos con la misma disciplina donde
el saludo el abrazo el beso es
fundamental donde somos mucho más
relajados en cuestiones de la
contingencia del manejo de los
protocolos entonces por ahí se debe ver
principalmente lo que se ha comentado
aquí es que el trabajo es el que
fundamentalmente hace que los hispanos
se contagian más no tanto el racismo
creo yo y también sucede con los
afroamericanos
muy bien gracias mauricio vámonos ahora
con nuestra corresponsal de nueva york-
mamen sala hablamos específicamente de
las propuestas que se han hecho estos
dos días lo que hemos escuchado el día
de hoy que por cierto ya van varios de
los demócratas protagonistas que se han
pronunciado lo decíamos el senador chuck
schumer el ex presidente bill clinton
salí gates la ex procuradora general
interina todavía falta la esposa del
candidato joe biden que han dicho sobre
el tema sanitario los objetivos que se
han propuesto es por ejemplo expandir el
servicio de salud mental a reducir el
costo de los medicamentos entre otros
pronunciamientos de los demócratas que
tan posible que tan real es lograr estos
objetivos
pues esa es la pregunta clave yo creo
que tan posible es poder realmente
llevar a cabo lo que están prometiendo
que al final no olvidemos que estamos en
medio de una pandemia se está quitando
está quitar aprovechando de esa parte en
la que miles de estadounidenses han
perdido algún familiar o han sufrido el
coronavirus y se han dado cuenta del
sistema sanitario que atraque tiene el
país y cuáles son las digamos las
carencias que tiene entonces es una es
una muy buena línea de pues de utilizar
para conseguir votantes en esta en esta
campaña pero ojo porque no es tan real a
la hora de aplicarla y luego también
dentro del mismo partido demócrata no se
acaban de poner de acuerdo entre lo que
quiere el ala más izquierdista y la que
no no debemos olvidar que como decía
nuestra compañía diana bernís antes
llega a estas convenciones con bastante
poder con unos con un gran número de
delegados y al final dentro del mismo
partido vemos esa unidad que se está
intentando transmitir en todo momento
pero hasta qué punto es real
entonces pues bueno en la cuestión del
coronavirus también tenemos que tener en
cuenta que vaivén se ha dado cuenta de
que le ha funcionado es decir el
candidato demócrata ha estado durante
casi cinco meses encerrado en su casa
haciendo una campaña virtual que le ha
funcionado hasta qué punto no le ha
funcionado la campaña virtual o le ha
funcionado el colocarse al lado de los
estadounidenses y estar con ellos en esa
lucha contra el coronavirus apoyarle
abrazarles no cosa que no hemos visto
por parte igual del presidente don al
tram entonces ha sabido utilizar
perfectamente como como bueno pues como
herramienta para esta lucha la cuestión
del coronavirus y sobre todo la cuestión
de la cobertura médica con todos los
problemas que estamos viendo ahora que
están aflorando no bien mamen sala pues
vamos a seguir hablando de lo que nos
identifica pero con diana castañeda
corresponsal de france 24 en washington
diana mamá en sala nos está
identificando las estrategias que ha
utilizado baiden recientemente por
ejemplo enfatiza en que desde casa él ha
sabido aprovechar políticamente el
avance
el coronavirus en eeuu por su parte
donald trump lo escuchamos por ejemplo
del ex presidente bill clinton nos ha
mostrado como una persona abierta pero
eso también puede ser favorable
electoralmente presentarse como un
candidato de la ley y del orden como es
tu visualización en general de estas dos
posturas de estas dos estrategias
específicas jana
si digamos que esto le dio resultado
durante la primera campaña a la
presidencia a donaldson para poder ser
elegido y recordemos que también centró
su campaña en la construcción de este
gran muro en la frontera y también
mostrando a los inmigrantes como
criminales no digamos que desde que
llegó a la casa blanca tomó políticas
que que han llevado a una dirección más
fuerte hacia los inmigrantes que en este
caso debido a lo que está ocurriendo
ahora y el efecto que ha tenido en la
población inmigrante la pandemia podrían
ser contraproducentes
no hay que olvidar que el presidente
donald trump intentó cancelar
recientemente
las visas a los estudiantes extranjeros
también el canceló visas a profesionales
e inmigrantes que trabajaban en áreas de
tecnología o de investigación científica
también ha intentado en varias
oportunidades y ha sido frenado por las
cortes quitar los beneficios a
inmigrantes que llegaron siendo niños a
los eeuu como son los jóvenes
su inmersos soñadores como se les conoce
y quitarles el beneficio de dacca al
igual que tps para los inmigrantes que
salieron en digamos de sus países por
circunstancias extraordinarias y ahora
está intentando también tomar medidas
para que las personas que están
solicitando asilo no puedan trabajar
mientras saleh su proceso de asilo así
que estas políticas de inmigración tan
fuertes son las que han llevado a que se
pueda despertar este gigante dormido
como se le conoce a los votantes latinos
porque además no solamente podrían
llegar a movilizarse a las urnas pero
también han visto como por fuera de los
beneficios y ayudas federales del
gobierno durante la pandemia han quedado
los inmigrantes que viven indocumentados
en el país cerca de 12 millones de
inmigrantes que no pudieron recibir los
cheques de ayuda por parte del
presidente donaldson durante esta
pandemia así que todo esto esperan los
demócratas puedan
movilizar a los a los inmigrantes y que
digamos esa narrativa que utiliza el
presidente de donald trump de de una
mano más fuerte pues en el tema de
inmigración al parecer en esta en este
momento que está viviendo el país no
podría ser tan efectiva bien muchas
gracias
diana vamos a ahora a hablar del proceso
electoral que está haciendo pues vaya un
tema central polémico envuelve por
ejemplo el voto por correo envuelve
también anuncios que han hecho en contra
los mismos demócratas no sólo los
republicanos de desconfianza en el
proceso de electoral estadounidense y
por ello empiezo con rafael piñero que
tiene expertise en este tema el profesor
analista de problemas políticos
contemporáneos rafael piñeros las
elecciones se están dando en medio de
esta nueva polémica por las votaciones
por correo esta práctica que se espera
sea masiva pues el país está atravesando
la pandemia del coronavirus porque
donald trump asegura que va a haber
fraude
yo creo que esa declaración hay que
matizarla es difícil entender que el
sistema político estadounidense a través
del sistema de voto por correo
electrónico vaya a haber fraude pero lo
que el servicio nacional postal ha
recomendado a aquellos estados en los
que se prevé que haber una votación
masiva de personas es que lo hagan con
un tiempo prudencial de al menos dos
semanas ese elemento obliga a que haya
una destinación de fondos mucho más
fidedigna mucho más precisa por parte de
las autoridades estatales y ahí es donde
los demócratas se encuentran en un
terreno fértil para criticar la postura
del partido republicano y del presidente
en particular yo creo que e
y tenía razón un senador demócrata
cuando la semana pasada afirmaba que no
hay que politizar lo que es una tarea
administrativa y es principalmente que
el servicio nacional cumpla bien su
función ahora qué tenemos que hacer en
los partidos políticos y los políticos
para ponernos de acuerdo para que eso se
pueda llevar a cabo ese es el elemento
más importante cuando el presidente
denuncia que hay fallas que hay
debilidades hombre si miramos no hay un
estado en el cual se maneje una política
de manera perfecta ni la de correos ni
la de salud ni la de infraestructura
siempre hay un desafío por cumplir en
ese sentido el llamado de algunos
moderados es que tenemos que hacer
entonces para ponernos de acuerdo y
pongámonos de acuerdo ya para que en
octubre o para que en la segunda mitad
de octubre no vayamos a tener
dificultades otro elemento que
denunciado al servicio nacional postales
con como qué vamos a hacer con los votos
que lleguen justo a algunos días después
o en algún momento después cuando se han
cerrado las votaciones ahí hay un
desafío que también creo que se puede
solucionar si se encuentran elementos en
común el problema es que desde hace
algunos años ya esa situación no ha sido
fácil de alcanzar no sólo en materia de
servicio nacional de postal sino en
materia de impuestos de salud o de
educación he ahí el problema y el
elemento central creo yo la politización
el hecho de desprestigiar el servicio
nacional de de postal hace que la gente
tenga un desincentivo para acercarse a
ese sistema votar eso sin duda alguna le
conviene a donald trump que fue elegido
con la popa con la población que menos
voto para unas elecciones presidenciales
en las últimas cinco que se realizan
entonces ese tipo de elementos sin duda
alguna hace de división de incapacidad o
de temor sobre las elecciones hacen que
donald trump
punto y muy bien muy bien pues rafael
piñero es el especialista en problemas
políticos contemporáneos es momento de
escuchar nuevamente ahora que lo podemos
retomar
justo está hablando joe biden escuchamos
[Música]
quién está hablando sigue la convención
demócrata y queremos escuchar a la
estratega demócrata desde hace rato pero
se había caído su comunicación entonces
ah bueno es que se está llevando a cabo
en este momento la nominación oficial
del candidato joe biden escuchamos todos
significa todo para mí para mi familia y
los veré el jueves muchas gracias muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y ese es el momento en que es
formalmente nominado joe biden como
candidato presidencial demócrata que
buscará llegar a la casa blanca quitar
al partido republicano que lidera que
está presidiendo en la casa blanca-
donald trump y pues yo baiden sigue pues
dando de qué hablar este tipo de
convenciones que al finalizar los
discursos normalmente se escucha un
aplauso pero en el lugar
ahora como podemos ver o se escucha un
silencio abrumador o se escuchan
aplausos vía digital lo cual pues sigue
siendo muy extraño le voy a preguntar
este a rodolfo por si coincide conmigo
el analista político
finalmente estratega demócrata que ya
podemos escuchar te rodolfo qué opinión
te merece que ya es formalmente nominado
joe biden vamos a seguir contigo
empezamos con esta pregunta
gracias por también de regreso es una
excelente noticia
presentarse de esa forma es un señor que
no solamente guarda referencias con el
presente sino que con el pasado también
es posiblemente el vínculo perfecto para
hacer la transición a quienes serán los
líderes del futuro y lo hace de una
forma que no visualizamos hace seis
meses atrás y sin embargo es una
situación que nos ha obligado a vivir
diez meses diez años en el futuro en el
cómic cambio en nuestras vidas y con
ello la política no quedó exenta de ese
proceso y él lo ha sabido asumir con la
responsabilidad de colomer y está en un
hombre no solamente noble sino es un
hombre gallardo es un hombre a quien
cuya integridad incluso y su compasión
por los demás ese ejemplo de lo que es
los eeuu de américa y lo hace en familia
lo hace entre amigos lo hacen tres
seguidores que aunque se sientan estar a
lo mejor físicamente a más de mil
kilómetros de donde está el o mucho más
lo hace sentir cómo es su día a diario
como lo conoce aquel que conduce el tren
o aquel a quien le compra el boleto
antes de montarse es un hombre quien a
la edad de 29 años perdió su familia un
maxi
entre su esposa y su hija y ya había
ganado la senaduría y optó por servirle
al pueblo americano y lo hizo con una
sola condición de que cada noche él
regresaría a casa montado en ese tren
desde washington hasta delaware todos
los días que estuvo en el congreso él
volvía y regresaba y dormía con sus
niños es un hombre ejemplar de verdad
incluso las palabras de el señor de
lindsey graham que en el senador del
carro del sur se le aguaron los ojos a
hablar de llover quien no le gusta quien
no quiera yo bailé si es un regreso a la
normalidad a lo normal lo que estamos
viviendo ahora no es normal no lo es
rodolfo qué opinión te merece el peso de
bernie sanders en los acuerdos que hemos
visto transcurrir en estas jornadas y
también ya lo había mencionado
mencionado perdona alexandría ocasio
cortez ella le dio el voto a sanders
cuál es tu opinión en general de toda
esta noticia
bueno el que ya llegó el voto a sanders
se habla sobre lo anime que es ella
ella sigue fijada en las posiciones que
plantea sanders que creo que en su
momento
cualquier gobierno ya sea el demócrata o
republicano tendrán que asumir muchos de
los planteamientos que está haciendo el
peronista 'no el señor es el que no crea
que eeuu posee un gobierno de carácter
social está muy equivocado lo que pasa
es que durante mucho tiempo la retórica
del partido derecha es crear a veces y
si se quiere hasta un temor sobre el
gran cuco del comunismo que ya no existe
del socialismo que es simplemente una
palabra mal utilizada en américa porque
muy bien que funciona en europa donde es
implementado nosotros tenemos una
economía capitalista tenemos un sistema
democrático y tenemos un gobierno que
posee y ejecuta acciones de carácter
social el que no entiendo acepte eso
entonces simplemente no sabe cómo
funcionan los eeuu y lamento aquellos
que toman tiempo de poder encontrar
en estímulo o algún tipo de motivación
en lo que en lo que es el señor donald
trump de verdad hay que tener el
autoestima muy muy bajo para encontrar
algún tipo de renovación espiritual en
el candidato bien rodolfo aprovecho
porque ahorita está bien la comunicación
contigo no es el que se nos caiga otra
vez que respondes a lo que se ha
pronunciado por parte de las posturas
republicanas no sólo en los medios
también en esta emisión de los
señalamientos que se le ha hecho a los
demócratas por ejemplo de exagerar el
movimiento blacks likes mother tienes
algún pronunciamiento de lo que hemos
dicho en esta emisión desde las posturas
republicanas me sorprende que yo utilicé
en la herramienta de de querer incluso
insinuar que se ha acelerado o se ha
incrementado la proyección de un grupo
como tal porque cuando hubieron los
disturbios de los white de los white los
de aquellos que salieron
en 2 caroline ahí salieron con antorchas
a decir que ningún judío lo va a
reemplazar o que ningún afroamericano lo
va a reemplazar y que el presidente fue
capaz de decir que habían de ambos lados
habían personas buenas y habían personas
malas es decir limpiar sin justificar el
racismo al cual le estábamos hablando as
un momentico uno de los otros invitados
estaba haciendo referencia del racismo
sistemático porque sólo hay que ver que
de cada 100 mil hombres 1800 cada
100.000 hombres encarcelados perdón
desde interior a la cifra de cada
100.000 hombres negros 1800 de ellos
están encarcelados seis veces más que
cualquier persona de tez blanca y el
doble de un latinoamericano así cuando
un policía detiene para poner una
contravención de conducir a un
afroamericano tiene cinco posibilidades
más que un hombre blanco a salir muerto
de ese intercambio aún sin poseer un
arma de fuego
imagínense si no es sistemático que tres
los latinoamericanos tienen tres veces
más posibilidades salir muertos de un
intercambio donde un policía le va a
poner una contravención de tráfico si
algo que puede ser una persona blanca
muy bien rodolfo pues vamos a seguir
contigo el estratega demócrata quien nos
habla justo en el momento en que se
confirma por parte de los demócratas la
nominación del ex vicepresidente joe
biden como el candidato a la presidencia
de eeuu ya no tenemos que llamarlo
virtual candidato es oficialmente yo
bailé en el candidato demócrata que
busca llegar a la casa blanca y que se
enfrentará al presidente de donald trump
vamos a retomar el tema justo antes de
esta noticia estábamos hablando del
proceso electoral porque está generando
dudas no habíamos hablado de la parte
republicana de como donald trump le da
desconfianza el voto por correo pero no
habíamos hablado de la parte demócrata y
para ello me gustaría preguntarle a
mauricio cárdenas nuestro corresponsal
en los ángeles lo que ha dicho la parte
demócrata específicamente quiero
resaltar lo que dijo ayer por ejemplo
obama la esposa del ex presidente barack
obama ella dijo que están cerrando los
lugares de votación en los vecindarios
minoritarios y está interviniendo y se
está interviniendo en la lista de
electores en que se basa la ex primera
dama y en general cómo está el proceso
electoral estadounidense mauricio
alan yo creo que realmente en torno a
este tema ha habido muchos genios y
mucha publicidad del lado demócrata para
enlodar un poco lo que ha hecho el
presidente de trump y lo que ha dicho
estar en contra del voto por correo que
esto pero daría pie a un fraude
electoral y realmente pues esa no ha
sido lo que hemos visto en la realidad
en las calles ni se han tirado los los
centros de donde se ponen los sobres del
correo con algunas fotos que aparecieron
en todas las redes sociales era un
centro de acopio donde se pintan y donde
se arreglan y se refaccionan esas
casillas para enviar el correo y no
ponen las cartas esas azul del servicio
postal entonces así ha sido simplemente
como una campaña como lo que hemos visto
creo que si algo ha traído a la
presidencia de donald trump es ha sido
volver a esas campañas políticas sucias
que ahora cuentan con las redes sociales
entonces aparecen este tipo de noticias
sin que realmente
verificar y se adora asombro culpan de
eso pues los demócratas también han
caído en lo mismo en soltar noticias al
aire que realmente no terminan siendo
entonces por ahora eso que dicen los
demócratas en no lo hemos visto en la
realidad ni leen y va a ser la supresión
o el querer quitarle el poder al correo
para esta votación que se vienen 3 de
noviembre ni tampoco se ha hecho con la
fuerza que ha dicho el presidente trono
aunque lo reconoció en un discurso que
no está de acuerdo en que se le dé en
estos billones de dólares al correo
porque es lo que quieren los demócratas
para ganar la elección
según el presidente bien mauricio
cárdenas nuestro corresponsal en los
ángeles y ahora nos vamos a miami
florida donde está el estratega
republicano quiero preguntarle me
imagino cómo ha de haber tomado la
noticia de que ya sea y se haga oficial
la candidatura de joe biden como
rumbo a la candidatura perdón demócrata
y yo bailé en rumbo a la casa blanca
politólogo julio feeling además vamos a
volver a tocar el tema del proceso
electoral y es que el presidente de
donald trump no ha presentado pruebas de
que el voto por correo pueda tener
fraude pero sí también es bastante
atípico que una organización que sea
considerada a política como el servicio
postal estadounidense está envuelta en
estos temas tan polémicos cuál es su
opinión en general el servicio postal de
las próximas elecciones y también
empiece rápidamente nada más con la
redacción de la candidatura oficial de
joe biden como candidato demócrata rumbo
a la casa blanca como el candidato
demócrata rumbo al 2012 ha estado no
creo que hallar la casa blanca era
primero antes de contestar con mucho
gusto tu pregunta
el señor bardem habrá montado mucho el
tren pero la realidad es que le llenó el
bolsillo a toda su familia y después de
los clinton es probablemente la persona
más corrupta que ha tenido los eeuu y
podemos tener un debate si el tiempo
alcanzar y los invito a otro programa
para para hablar sobre eso que tiene una
gran enriquecido a su familia de una
manera cracia usando la influencia
política que ha tenido y sobre la
evidencia empírica para para eso otra
cosa hay una gran diferencia entre la
socialdemocracia que hay en finlandia en
noruega y en suecia a lo que es el
socialismo
y si realmente la persona no sabe la
diferencia no está calificado para estar
dando una opinión política de ninguna
forma
así que esto es fundamental entender y
el decir que el marxismo no existe es es
un acto de embrutecimiento colosal el
lean el manifiesto de blacklight matters
o sea esto lo estoy diciendo yo busquen
los sus fundadores quienes están han
guiado ese movimiento que lo fundaron
son marxistas convencido entonces lo que
pasa que naturalmente quieren tapar el
sol con un dedo esto un caballo de troya
ahora vamos a tu pregunta y una cosa más
el decir que las elecciones no se pueden
robar mira en el año 60 en nixon y que
dice
por 100 mil votos en aquel momento 100
mil votos decidió la elección y una
cantidad de regularidades en chicago y
en partes de texas
justo chicago que es una maquinaria del
partido demócrata y texas con el vice el
candidato
johnson pues probablemente sí nixon
hubiera querido pedir un conteo hubiera
resultado el ganador hay una gran
diferencia y esto hablan es muy
importante destacar que no lo escuchado
sino lo que escuchamos de la narrativa
en una boleta ausente es muy diferente a
la votación universal que están
promoviendo los demócratas la bola está
ausente requiere un chequeo sistemático
y constante de que el votante todavía
está vivo de que el votante existe o sea
la persona tiene que ir contestando
periódicamente de que todavía vive que
está vivo que sigue en el lugar es para
asegurar el voto lo que están pidiendo
los demócrata lo que buscan es esto es
echar al culpable la culpa no es el
correo de confianza del correo no la
culpa es del partido demócrata que está
buscando una forma de robarse las
elecciones por medio de una votación que
no se puede contabilizar no hay tiempo
para establecer un mecanismo seguro de
voto entonces bajo el pretexto de que
todos los votos sean contados claro los
votos hasta los votos de los muertos
como hemos visto más entre 200 y 500 mil
votos si reúnes todos los estados
errados falsos a personas con entre los
que están muertos que no viven ahí eso
lo hemos estado viviendo eso es un hecho
real y entonces una elección que podría
ser reñida es un gran peligro y ahora
que se ha oficializado la candidatura
demócrata de joe biden quien se
enfrentará a donald trump en noviembre
qué papel juegan las presidencias
anteriores hablando la de obama y la de
yo bailé
en cuanto a esta lección mira hay dos
personas claves discúlpeme julio feeling
es momento de escuchar a juncker y quién
está hablando ahora el ex secretario de
estado lo escuchamos
formamos un acuerdo para atacar el
cambio climático detuvimos el debe volar
antes de que se convirtiera una pandemia
y heredó una economía creciente y un
mundo más pacífico y como todos los
demás que era lo llevó a la bancarrota
cuando este presidente va al exterior
es una vergüenza le escribe cartas de
moras de dictadores y ataca a nuestros
aliados no necesitamos un presidente del
cual la gente se esté riendo y que
pretenda que rusia no atacó nuestras
elecciones ahora en la cena no hace nada
cuando rusia poner recompensas por las
cabezas de nuestras tropas no sabe cómo
defender nuestras tropas solamente le
interesa defenderse a sí mismo
este es el punto nuestros intereses
nuestros ideales y nuestros hombres y
mujeres valientes en uniforme no pueden
permitirse otros cuatro años de donald
trump nuestras tropas no pueden salirse
de esas zonas peligrosas y escondiéndose
en un búnker como lo hace donald trump
se necesita un presidente que nos apoye
y el presidente biden lo hará en la
brújula moral de bailén siempre ha
apuntado en la dirección correcta
luchando contra la parte en la lucha
para despertar al mundo de los problemas
y de los balcanes y comprende que
ninguno de los problemas de este mundo
ni las armas nucleares ni construir
reconstruir después del coven y el
terrorismo y claramente no la crisis
climática ninguna de sus temas puede ser
resuelto sin unir a las naciones la
fortaleza con fortaleza y con humildad
yo comprende nuestros valores y lo
significa él comprende que no se puede
llevar la democracia al rededor del
mundo si no la prácticas en casa y él
sabe que incluso en estados unidos de
américa
necesitan amigos en este planeta antes
de donald trump hablábamos de el
excepcionalismo estadounidense lo único
excepcional de la política incoherente
de hecho es que ha hecho que nuestra
nación que además aislada que nunca
antes
joe biden sabe que somos excepcionales
por como excepcionales porque hacemos
cosas excepcionales en el 6 de julio de
1944 los jóvenes estadounidenses dieron
sus vidas en las calles de normandía
para liberar al mundo de la tiranía y de
esa guerra creamos la paz y
reconstruimos el mundo y ese fue y sigue
siendo algo excepcional es lo opuesto de
todo lo que donald trump defiende este
momento es un momento para luchar por la
seguridad de estados unidos y del mundo
solamente joe biden puede hacer que
estados unidos lidere como eeuu de nuevo
si están de acuerdo en bien join al 303
este puede john kerry el ex secretario
de estado un nominado demócrata a la
presidencia en 2004 y una de las figuras
demócratas de más alto perfil que ha
apoyado la carrera y la nominación de
joe biden durante la precampaña
regresamos entonces con nuestro
estratega republicano julio seal y en
julio nos estabas mencionando que papel
están jugando y jugarán las ex
presidencias hablando de clinton
hablando de obama en las aspiraciones
que tenga joe biden y por favor igual tu
opinión de lo que acabas de escuchar por
parte de john kerry que fue duro contra
la presidencia de donald trump habló de
temas internacionales dijo que está
perdiendo eeuu el liderazgo
internacional se refirió a corea del
norte y los nuevos lazos que tiene con
este país las que tiene con rusia pero
que ahora está 21 está más aislado que
nunca son entonces estas dos preguntas
te escuchamos
aislado mira primero el papel
preponderante de los dos expresidentes
que mencionaste bill clinton pues no
realmente en el sentido práctico no
figura nada de obama si tiene gran
influencia en la ala radical del partido
yo pienso que él no hubiera querido que
las cosas fueran de esta manera el logro
bastante llevar al país hacia la
izquierda
siguiendo un formulario del tipo las
marchas por las instituciones de un tipo
de socialismo fabiano entonces pues se
le vino abajo con todas estas
manifestaciones subversivas motines
etcétera pero mira hay que destacar el
presidente que más colaboró con rusia
fue barack obama barack obama le quitó
la existencia a un cráneo para
defenderse contra rusia le quitó el
escudo anti-misiles que estaba pidiendo
europa en efecto no puede haber
encontrado el mejor aliado putin que en
la práctica que es barack obama en
cuanto a la crisis climática que esa es
la narrativa que están vendiendo es una
visión del cientificismo político que
quieren vender la ecología política o
sea hay una visión de verdad y una
visión
política pese a la gran abundancia de
científicos que han discrepado incluso
muchos que pertenecieron al movimiento
ecológico de la izquierda y lo han
abandonado por considerarlo que
están falseando información y causando
una histeria innecesaria sin embargo el
clima cambia el clima cambia siempre ha
cambiado pero aquí la idea es echarle la
culpa al sistema de libre empresa en la
democracia no en china comunista ni nada
de eso entonces está la narrativa que
están siguiendo entonces hay que
entender hay que entender que si tienen
una inquietud de la salubridad la
administración de obama dejó a este país
sin caretas o sea realmente fue
vergonzoso la situación en que dejó
pacto vergonzosamente con irán hizo una
promoción del islamismo radical chiita
de estabilizando totalmente el medio
oriente siria la dictadura de siria
estaba mejor te interrumpa discúlpame
julio chilling vamos a escuchar alcohol
impagos por primera vez mis padres me
llevaron a eso comenzó una exacta ruta
de servicio
que me hizo subir hasta hacer
yo aprendí con los mismos que los padres
yo apoyo a joe biden para la presidencia
de eeuu porque esos valores siguen
definiendo y tenemos que restaurar esos
valores estamos un comandante en jefe
que cuide las tropas de la misma manera
que cuidaría su propia familia
para joe biden esto no significa que
tiene que aprender viene de la
experiencia que comparte con municiones
de familia de militares esto es
cambiando a su propio hijo a la guerra
orando de a dios para que pudiera volver
seguro es un presidente que todos
tenemos el recurso de saludar y nunca
dudar hemos puesto que él estará con
nuestros amigos y se enfrentarán
nuestros adversarios nunca lo
encontrarás él va a confiar en nuestros
diplomáticos y las agencias de
inteligencia para que sea su trabajo
cuando alguien nos amen en ese lapso se
enfrentará a nuestros adversarios con
fortaleza y con experiencia ellos sabrán
el que él va en serio
porque desde el día uno va a restaurar
el liderazgo estadounidense y nuestra
autoridad moral será un presidente que
sabe que estados unidos es fuerte
como queramos con el poder del ejemplo y
el ejemplo de nuestro poder para
restaurar el liderazgo de eeuu de
restaurar las alianzas que necesitamos
para atender las peligros que enfrenta
el país desde la proliferación nuclear
hasta el cambio climático hoy somos un
país dividido y tenemos un presidente
que hace todo en su poder para que sea
así y mantenernos de sonrisa qué
diferencia será tener un presidente que
nos une que restaure nuestra alma yo
creo que somos el mismo país que trabajo
mis padres a estas costas y que inspira
en todo el mundo es en eeuu que yo
guardé me va a liderar con el próximo
presidente gracias
escuchamos a colin powell él es militar
diplomático político estadounidense que
fue general en el ejército de eeuu
alcanzando el rango de general de cuatro
estrellas él enfatizó el apoyo a joe
biden dijo que enfrentará a adversarios
y que tiene la experiencia el carácter y
la decencia para unirnos a un eeuu que
no está unido así lo identificó y
restaurar la grandeza de este país
merecemos una persona con integridad y
buen juicio es algo de lo que mencionaba
colin powell y es momento de regresar
con nuestro estratega republicano quien
nos estaba finalizando su participación
pero también le tenía otra pregunta para
julio schilling julio si quieres
culminar lo que estabas mencionando
previamente a la intervención de colin
powell también te voy a robar para otra
pregunta como no pero no prefiero
señalar dos cositas uno que comentado
ha apoyado a través de su vida mucho más
presidentes demócratas o sea candidato
demócrata
según esto y eso es un derecho que él
tiene pero es importante alan destacar
una cosa porque uno de tus invitados fue
dejó la impresión que el que no conoce
bien la circunstancia de lo estable pues
puede quedarse confundido diciendo de
que un negro tiene mucho más los eeuu
mucho más posibilidad de ser arrestado y
bueno ya tarda la intención de que eso
pues conlleva un prejuicio no lo dijo
pero lo quiere dar a entender mira el
13% de la población que es la población
negros eeuu comete el 53 por ciento de
los crímenes violentos
repito el 13% de la población comete el
53 por ciento de los crímenes violentos
el 96 por ciento de los homicidios de
los negros es cometido por otro negro no
por un blanco el año pasado
ustedes saben cuántos ciudadanos negros
estadounidenses murieron a manos de un
policía negro desarmado
[Música]
99 el año pasado hubo 375 millones de
interacciones entre la policía los eeuu
y los ciudadanos estadounidenses 375
millones las estadísticas no rinden el
validez a sustentar que hay racismo
sistémico si hay determinadas
desventajas pero eso no se debe al todo
lo contrario todo lo contrario o sea los
negros estados y tienen preferencia a
los créditos preferencia entrar en
universidades así que si alguien se está
discriminando en el sentido pues serían
los los hombres blancos los eeuu que no
son la mayoría dicho sea de paso
entonces esto es importante poner en un
contexto porque es de nuevo tristemente
la narrativa que el partido demócrata
usa para tratar de ganar elecciones es
raspar y promover los sentimientos bajos
para ganar votos muy bien pues
te te adelantaba julio que me gustaría
ir planteando te esta pregunta si te
merece alguna opinión que la congresista
neoyorquina alexandra ocasio cortes haya
reafirmado las ideas progresistas del
senador de izquierda a bernie sanders si
desde tu perspectiva esto tendría pues
un mensaje equivocado o poca unión por
parte del partido demócrata pero como ya
está muy cerca a hablar la esposa de joe
biden jill biden pues ahorita retomamos
contigo mientras tanto me voy a enlazar
con mamen sala que ella está en nueva
york'
precisamente para salir del tema del
proceso electoral
mamen recortar fondos para el servicio
postal es esto una amenaza para la
democracia estadounidense hay que
recordar que el director del servicio
postal aceptó testificar ante el
congreso la próxima semana que se puede
esperar de este tema
sí pues va a ser un muy interesante
escucharlo sobre todo porque de él
depende que millones de estadounidenses
confíen en una forma de votar que va a
ser segura mitad de la pandemia está que
nos encontramos pero yo creo que más
allá de todo este ruido que estamos
haciendo con el servicio de es con el
servicio postal lo que donald trama está
intentando hacer con esta situación es
que él sabe ahora si por fin ha visto
digamos las orejas al lobo y él sabe que
puede perder estas elecciones entonces
desde mi punto de vista está preparando
un terreno para que en caso de que eso
ocurra poder achacárselo a algo no
entonces yo creo que al final toda esta
problemática con el post office no deja
de ser más que una cortina de humo para
esconder la realidad y la realidad dice
que en estos momentos
joe biden le gana por nueve puntos en
las encuestas nacionales y que cada vez
más cuenta con el apoyo de votantes
independientes que por lo general suelen
apoyar al partido republicano y esta vez
se están inclinando más por los
demócratas entonces la semana que viene
lo que vamos a escuchar pues va a ser
algo que bueno que de momento no sabemos
muy bien por dónde va a ir lo que sí que
está claro es que va a significar un
punto de inflexión para una
lecciones que desde luego no están
haciendo nada al uso muy bien mamen sala
muchas gracias vámonos ahora con rafael
piñero es el profesor de relaciones
internacionales te advierto rafael que
te puede interrumpir en cualquier
momento ya que no tardé en hablar la
esposa de joe biden qué opinión te
merece lo que nos ha mencionado tanto el
estratega demócrata pero sobre todo el
estratega republicano quien se ha
referido a tus pronunciamientos durante
esta emisión varias veces si quieres
añadir algo y si no pues vámonos
directamente con lo que se viene con el
futuro te escuchamos
bien yo quisiera retomar sobre un
elemento supremamente importante como lo
mencioné en la primera intervención hoy
vamos a dar a conocer al candidato todos
y cada uno de los interlocutores o
miembros que han hablado han hecho
referencia a porque joe biden es un buen
candidato especialmente los dos últimos
el ex secretario de estado colin powell
y john kerry hicieron énfasis en sus
credenciales en materia de política
exterior no se nos olvide que joe biden
fue durante muchos años jefe y
participante en el comité de asuntos
exteriores porque el liderazgo que era
uno de los temas más importantes porque
el américa weight game es un fracaso es
un fracaso porque eeuu no está más cerca
de sus aliados es un fracaso porque ha
generado problemas y conflictos que no
tenía no es cierto la cia y algunas
otras organizaciones mostraban como el
acuerdo con irán era efectivo y se
estaba cumpliendo la guerra con china
fue creada durante esta administración
ahora va a ser bastante difícil salir de
ese elemento si hay un cambio de
presidente sin
no será no será así y con algunos
aliados europeos especialmente con
alemania hay profundas grietas que en
materia de política exterior se abrir
por eso la selección de estos dos ex
secretarios de estado ha sido
fundamental porque reafirma el carácter
internacional los eeuu pueden liderar
como lo hace es lo que separa a
republicanos y demócratas los
republicanos afirman que los estados
unidos pueden liderar con la fuerza de
ser el primero la primera economía la
más sólida la más grande los demócratas
lo hacen a partir de podemos liderar
desde atrás hay que saber unirse a
ciertas causas multilaterales como el
acuerdo de país lo dijo en la revista
conducir
luego la revista foreign affairs el
candidato yo bailé en mayo pasado hay
que retornar a lo multilateral en el año
2018 los eeuu no firmé un solo acuerdo
ni económico ni comercial ni social con
ningún estado a nivel internacional eso
no pasaba hace más de 65 años volver a
lo multilateral significa un compromiso
y retorno una idea muy importa
que los dos tanto john kerry como colin
powell tratan de dejar en claro y es una
vieja idea de norteamericana eeuu lo
hace bien en el exterior porque su
sistema político refleja su fortaleza lo
que demuestra lo que han sido los
últimos tres años de administración es
profundas divisiones cuando hay división
en los partidos tradicionales en los
eeuu eso es aprovechado en el exterior
para ver que los eeuu no es capaz de
liderar causas que les convengan a todos
eeuu se ha beneficiado y cuando otros se
benefician de lo que estados unidos
impulsa es que hay un gran beneficio
para repartir entre distintos actores
ese es un elemento central al cual los
demócratas le van a hacer mucho énfasis
y por eso el tema de ayer y de hoy era
el liderazgo todos han hecho énfasis en
el liderazgo que tiene joe biden tanto a
nivel interno como en el ámbito
internacional bien profesor piñero
muchas gracias vámonos ahora con el
estratega demócrata con rodolfo por
rodolfo me gustaría que
digamos de lo que se viene pues estamos
en un contexto de reconciliación de
división de inclusión de diversidad todo
esto envuelve a la carrera electoral y
cómo se puede llegar a la ciudadanía que
todavía está indecisa que no decide si
por los demócratas y por los
republicanos en un electorado que es muy
interconectado que está muy activo en
redes sociales
yo me sentiría más cómodo si de verdad
yo parece estuviera enfrentando al
partido republicano el señor no es
republicano el señor trump es sabremos
en el futuro cuando lo hagamos
finalmente el análisis correspondiente a
los cuatro años que sirvió después de
que haya sido una respuesta en contra de
lo que nos vamos de los que muchos
consideraron el extremo de obama no
solamente una persona al amor del
pensamiento liberal de frente sino
también una persona de tez oscura pero
no me sentiría y creo que muchos
demócratas que quieren ese balance de
regreso un que dice que un hasta un jet
bus una persona que traiga de regreso la
coherencia del partido republicano
porque mientras más fuerte y coherente
es el partido republicano más fuerte es
la democracia de los eeuu es un balance
en los fundadores de esta nación crearon
no necesariamente el bipartidismo porque
el bipartito evolucionó hacia ello pero
finalmente el crecimiento y la evolución
de esas ideas originales dieron a cabo
con dos partes
ese balance necesario de sustitución
cada cuatro cuadras cada ocho años pero
siempre un balance entre lo conservador
y lo liberal
rodolfo algunos dicen este arroz ya se
coció que es una expresión desconozco si
la hayas escuchado de que pues cómo está
yo bailé en tan arriba de donald trump
parece llevar toda la ventaja pero las
encuestas resultaron engañosas en 2016
se puede repetir este fenómeno con las
encuestadoras se han equivocado antes y
ahorita pues no está tan diferente el
escenario qué opinión te merece pero las
encuestadoras si comenzamos a ver como
cuando dictaron que yo le podía ganar a
sumen podemos decir que esa fue la gran
primer error de las encuestadoras yo lo
que digo que ningún político que está
optando por la presidencia de ninguna
nación debe jamás interrumpo rodolfo por
un momento de escuchar a la doctora jill
biden
y los sonidos de una clase que llega con
lleno de posibilidad antes de que entren
los estudiantes el rumor de las ideas
que van y vienen a medida que exploramos
juntos del mundo las risas y los
pequeños son momentos de sorpresa que
encontramos en las cosas de las que
hablamos millones de veces cuando enseñe
inglés aquí en esta escuela pasaba mi
verano preparándome para el año quiero
empezar lleno de anticipación
pero este silencio es algo pesado se
puede escuchar la ansiedad y su eco en
los pasillos vacíos
no hay un olor a nuevos cuadernos ni a
pisos limpios aquí a esos niños y ahora
lo único que se ven son las cajas en
computadores y lo escucho de tantos de
ustedes la frustración de los padres que
tienen que trabajar mientras apoyan el
aprendizaje de sus hijos tienen miedo de
que sus niños se enfermen las
preocupaciones de todos aquellos que
trabajan sin suficiente protección la
desesperación en las filas en frente de
los bancos de alimentos y el dolor que
no se puede describir que sigue después
de cada último respiro cuando apagan un
ventilador como madre y como abuela como
estadounidense se me rompe el corazón
por la magnitud de estas pérdidas por el
fracaso de proteger a nuestras
comunidades
y la vida perdida que es irreemplazable
como tantos de ustedes me quedo
preguntándome si como mantengo segura a
mi familia ser madre llegó a mí de una
manera que nunca experiencia yo me
enamoré de un hombre y dos niños
pequeños que habían acabado pasar por
una pérdida terrible habían partido su
madre y su hermana nunca me imaginé a la
edad de 26 me estaría preguntando a mí
misma
como unes a una familia de nuevo yo
siempre le dijo a los niños
mamá nos envió ayer y cómo podría yo
pelear con ella entonces lo logramos
juntos en esos grandes momentos que
pasan a veces muy rápido en 2 times
givings y en los cumpleaños y en las
bodas en los vasitos mundanas que le dan
forma a nuestras vidas
con esas historias que nos contábamos
los fines de semana en las salas
escuchando los sonidos de las risas que
flotaban de arriba hacia abajo en la
casa a medida que yo ponía a los niños
en la cama cada noche mientras que yo
estudiaba para debajo de una lámpara de
la cocina
y encontramos que el amor une a las
familias el amor nos hace flexibles y
resistentes nos permite ser más que
nosotros mismos juntos y aunque no puede
protegernos de los dolores de la vida
puede darnos un refugio un hogar como
creamos de nuevo y completamos a una
familia de la misma manera cómo se hace
cómo se crea una nación
con amor y entendimiento con pequeños
actos de bondad con una fe
inquebrantable cuidándonos unos a otros
de pequeñas y grandes formas de una y
otra vez es lo que tantos de ustedes
están haciendo justo ahora por sus seres
queridos por personas que no conocen
siquiera por sus comunidades
aquellos hay algunos que quieren
decirnos que este país está dividido y
que nuestras diferencias no se puede
reconciliar pero eso no es lo que yo he
visto en los últimos meses nos estamos
uniendo y tomando los unos a otros
encontrando la gracia y la piedad en
estos momentos que muchos dan por
sentado hemos visto que las diferencias
son preciosas y nuestras igualdades
infinitas
hemos demostrado que el corazón de esta
nación aún está latiendo con coraje y
ese es el alma que joe biden por la cual
yo vaivén está luchando ahora
después de que murió nuestro hijo bow
del cáncer yo me preguntaba si realmente
iba a sentir alegría o iba a sonreír de
nuevo fue un verano
pero no quedaba ya calor para mí cuatro
días después del funeral de bon jovi joe
afeitándose imponiéndose su traje lo vi
frente al espejo respirando
y caminar de nuevo es el mundo que ya no
tenía nuestro hijo el regreso al trabajo
y eso es lo que él es hay momentos en
donde yo ni siquiera podido imaginar
cómo podía hacerlo como ponía un pie
enfrente del otro y seguía avanzando
pero siempre comprendí por qué lo hacía
lo hacía por la hija que como vince
convence a su hija de finalmente hacerse
un examen de cáncer de seno y la lleva a
la clínica por el estudiante que ha
sobrevivido al abuso pero que encuentra
el coraje para terminar su carrera y
crear una buena vida para sus hijos lo
hace por el niño pequeño cuya madre está
sirviendo como marín en irak
la llama y no se queda cuando lo único
que quiere para su cumpleaños es estar
con ella para todos aquellos a quien yo
da su número personal en los eventos y
con los que habla durante horas después
de la cena ayudándoles a sonreír después
de sus pérdidas sabiendo o haciéndoles
saber que no están solos lo hace por
ustedes
el propósito de joe siempre ha sido lo
que lo ha impulsado a avanzar su
fortaleza es algo que no se puede
detener y su fe es inquebrantable porque
no son los partidos políticos o los
políticos como tal o es algo que esté en
él está en la providencia de dios su fe
está en ustedes en nosotros
si tantas clases ahora están en silencio
los jardines aún están ahí pero si se
escucha de cerca se puede escuchar el
cambio en todo el país los educadores
los padres los trabajadores de
emergencias personas de todos los
orígenes están luchando unos por otros
nosotros no nos hemos rendido
simplemente necesitamos el liderazgo
digno de este país un liderazgo digno de
ustedes un liderazgo honesto que nos
unan nuevamente que nos ayude a
recuperar de esta pandemia y nos ayuda a
preparar para lo que pueda venir en el
futuro liderazgo que realmente nos ayude
a re imaginar cómo será esta nación
ese es yo
y el ica moda van a trabajar tan duro
como ustedes todos los días para hacer
que esta nación sea mejor y si yo tengo
el honor de servir como su primera dama
lo haré igualmente y con joe como
presidente estas clases van a llenarse
de risas y de posibilidades nuevamente
los pesos que llevamos en este momento
son muchos pero necesitamos alguien con
hombros fuertes yo sé que si confiamos
esta nación a joe él va a ser por sus
familias lo que dijo por él o por lo que
hizo por la nuestra unirnos
ya seamos completos de nuevo llevarnos
hacia el futuro en este momento de
necesidad manteniendo la promesa de eeuu
para todos nosotros
jill biden la esposa del el candidato
demócrata joe biden sus palabras ella es
profesora de inglés dijo en su discurso
ahora escuchamos porque es el amor de mi
vida la verdad es que es la persona más
fuerte que he conocido le importan mucho
las cosas y todos ustedes allí afuera en
el país simplemente piensen en su mejor
educación aquel que le dio la
posibilidad de creer en usted mismo ella
será la primera dama
esa es la primera dama que será el
vaivén vayan a joe biden puntocom
y gracias a todos los que de pronto
[Música]
están los aplausos posteriores del
pronunciamiento de jill biden que se
esperaba era para muchos el momento más
importante del día de hoy y de joe biden
que no se esperaba a que hablara después
de su esposa jill biden y que a pesar de
que dio pocas palabras si puede mandar
un mensaje claro y también previamente
había hablado joe biden pero únicamente
cinco palabras que es lo que dijo su
esposa jill biden que es profesora de
inglés ya lo mencionó que rompe esquemas
cuando su esposo era vicepresidente ella
continuó ejerciendo ella acentuó que
ahora se ven aulas vacías mostró que los
estadounidenses tienen desesperación
palabras de jill biden que se ve esta
desesperación en los bancos de alimentos
en las tasas de desempleo pintó un
panorama muy sombrío dijo que hay un
país dividido pero que se está uniendo
dijo cómo se puede rehacer una familia
rota propone que de la misma manera que
haces con una
nación con amor y comprensión con
pequeños actos de compasión con valentía
con fe inquebrantable también dijo que
el amor une a las familias mencionó el
caso de beau biden su hijo de 46 años
quien falleció en 2015 a causa de un
cáncer cerebral cuando se encontraba
hospitalizado en el centro médico walter
reed del ejército también colin powell
ya había mencionado el caso del hijo de
la pareja byd en el ex fiscal general el
hijo del estado de delaware era visto
como una estrella ascendente en la
política de eeuu tenía ambiciones
políticas pero había sufrido problemas
de salud en los últimos años de su vida
no tenía intenciones de postularse al
cargo de gobernador de delaware en 2016
el presidente barack obama en su momento
dijo que estaba de luto con michelle que
fue un hombre devoto profundamente leal
el tema del hijo de la pareja by the end
que no sólo fue mencionado por la esposa
sino también
por colin powell vamos nuevamente con
rodolfo con nuestro analista político
estratega demócrata precisamente ahora
que estamos celebrando la segunda noche
de la convención nacional demócrata
rodolfo tú nos estabas mencionando si
gusta cerrar tu idea de los sustos que
todavía puede tener la carrera demócrata
estabamos comparando que hace cuatro
años la primera ocasión que donald trump
buscó llegar a la casa blanca pues
también venía abajo en las encuestas y
algunos dicen que puede pasar una
sorpresa y que donald trump se puede
mantener sobre todo los republicanos
estaba cerrando esta idea pero en cuanto
a las cierres si te parece bien
coméntanos cómo viste el pronunciamiento
de jill biden y el inesperado
pronunciamiento también del ya oficial
candidato demócrata rumbo a la
presidencia estadounidense de verdad que
da gusto a lambert a una esposa
expresarse así sin tener que hablar
mentira de su esposo sabiendo todos que
esa es la calidad de hombre que este
país requiere en este momento de
turbulencia de necesita
de fin de pandemia de crisis es un
hombre que nos traiga de regreso al
centro al centro emocional al centro
espiritual el centro en un fin común
acción atraernos ese balance que viene
fresco se siente escuchar a una mujer
hablar así de su esposo sin tener que
titubear ni buscar palabras en el aire
sabiendo qué clase de hombre porque todo
el que lo conoce eventualmente sabe que
ese hombre es así y esta nación se
merece ese hombre y bailén no solamente
bueno para el partido demócrata y para
la nación sino para el sistema político
los eeuu porque va a obligar que el
partido republicano comience su
renovación que durante tantos años ha
dejado que caigan al punto de que ya
eventualmente resultó en la elección de
donald trump que no es un republicano no
es un conservador no es ni un pragmático
es un señor generador de crisis y cuando
comparten es todo lo contrario vamos a
saber que el futuro es predecible porque
él no se va a encaminar de la mano
tomado de la mano vamos a
caminar hacia el futuro diciendo la
verdad diario no hablando mentiras no
contradiciendo a los expertos no
contradiciendo a sus asesores no
inventando ideas imaginarias decir desde
estos conceptos de inyectarse el
limpiador de un fin para quitarte el
corona vista inventamos en cada día unos
nuevos temas de distracción no queremos
un hombre sensato coherente y sobre todo
con compasión
bien rodolfo todavía no me despido de ti
a pesar de que ya estamos llegando a los
análisis finales porque me gustaría
primero que cierren los corresponsales
de france 24 en nueva york nueva york
que washington los ángeles empezamos con
diana castañeda la corresponsal de
france 24 en la capital estadounidense
diana cuáles son tus conclusiones con
qué motivación empieza mañana la carrera
demócrata ya oficializada como candidato
joe biden y qué opinas en general de
esta jornada
bueno el día de hoy vimos como ya se
podía digamos ver como el candidato
demócrata estaba hablándole a los
estadounidenses del papel que podría
tener también su esposa de bardem como
primera dama de los eeuu y como ella
desde un lugar muy importante una aula
de clase porque muchos muchas familias
están preocupadas por enviar de nuevo
sus hijos a las escuelas en medio de la
pandemia pues buscan un liderazgo y ella
reforzó y mostró ese lado más humano y
ese lado digamos familiar de joe bayrén
reforzando y diciendo que es el líder un
líder honesto y sensato que necesita el
país pero también durante esta segunda
jornada se vio un tono más económico y
un tono
hablando más de inmigración por parte de
los demócratas hay que recordar que en
estas elecciones de noviembre del 3 de
noviembre no sólo se busca que los
demócratas vuelvan al liderazgo en la
casa blanca pero también vimos
schümann haciendo un llamado para los
votantes para que los demócratas puedan
tener el control del senado y de esta
manera tener mayor capacidad mayor
acción política y otro de los temas
sobre todo que es importante para que
los demócratas puedan obtener digamos
este liderazgo en el senado es poder
avanzar con el tema migratorio con una
reforma migratoria que ha sido una de
las promesas características de los
demócratas otro de los temas el que
vimos por parte de varios de los
speakers de las personas que estuvieron
hablando hoy durante esta convención fue
relacionado a la economía y el liderazgo
que podría tener bailén frente a esta
crisis económica que vive en los eeuu
con el desempleo con sectores muy
tradicionales y grandes de la economía
de los eeuu impactados como es el sector
del petróleo del sector automotriz así
que vimos un tono más económico
convención en esta segunda jornada y por
último también vimos ese lado más
progresista esa nueva generación de
líderes demócratas jóvenes con ideas de
digamos salud y educación
para la nación que son respaldados por
sandro espero que vimos por ejemplo en
voces como de ocasión cortes para mañana
se esperan pues grandes líderes del
partido demócrata de nuevo con más voces
de votantes y demócratas en todo el país
hablando de estos temas importantes que
han sido parte de esta convención como
es la pandemia y lo que puede ser el
liderazgo de bailén de cara a las
elecciones del mes de noviembre
diana nos despedimos de ti con una
pregunta más si es que como bien
identificaste hoy se habló del liderazgo
de joe biden de los demócratas en
general y también tuvo un aspecto mucho
más económico la jornada del día de hoy
desde que el ex presidente bill clinton
que pues para muchos era
un músculo el tema económico por los
indicadores financieros después de su
presidencia en eeuu que tan posible de
realizar son los objetivos económicos
demócratas como un aumento del salario
mínimo o fortalecer la infraestructura
del país y para todas todas esos
millones de personas sin empleo ahora en
eeuu consecuencia de la crisis que deja
el coronavirus a dónde pueden ir esos
votos
como lo mencionas son dos temas muy
importantes en medio de esta crisis el
incremento del salario mínimo por hora a
15 dólares que es un digamos un tema que
se logra negociar y llevar a los
consejos locales y estatales y que varía
en cada estado pero que digamos fue una
de las características en las cuales en
bailén decidió llevar este como una
plataforma de su campaña y que fue
digamos mencionado por sanders y uno de
los temas de negociación entre los dos
ahora vienen los demócratas también
tendrán que presentar un programa
agresivo de recuperación económica
durante y después de esta pandemia para
los pequeños negocios que están tratando
de salir adelante para las industrias
que hacen parte
de la la más profunda de lo que es los
eeuu y hay que recordar que la razón por
la cual el presidente don al trombo una
de las razones llegó a la casa blanca es
porque prometió en sus empleos a
industrias como la industria automotriz
y en estados en donde habían pues
industrias más tradicionales
estos mismos estados son los que están
afectados impuestos de trabajo así que
habrá que ver el impacto que tiene esto
en las urnas por parte de los votantes
pero definitivamente la recuperación
económica tiene que ser uno de los
epicentros de la plataforma que tenga
bailén de aquí a los próximos dos meses
muy bien bien a castilla muchas gracias
por tus completos reportes y estar
presente durante este especial diana
castaña corresponsal de france 24 en
washington en la capital estadounidense
nos vamos con la otra corresponsal que
tuvimos el día de hoy y es mamá en sala
la corresponsal de france 24 en nueva
york' en la gran manzana mamen cuál es
tu recopilación de este día que resalta
de la jornada de hoy
sí pues ha sido una segunda jornada en
la que hemos visto pues un final que ha
quedado bastante arriba creo que ese
mensaje de jill biden sobre cómo superar
el dolor dejará una profunda huella en
muchos estadounidenses que a lo largo de
esta pandemia han perdido algún familiar
así que creo que ha sido una buena forma
de conectar con el electorado además
creo también que hacía falta conocer un
poquito más a jill biden y ver qué bueno
no es por supuesto no no podría estar no
estaría a la altura de la ex primera
dama michelle obama pero también tiene
carisma como primera dama y va a ser muy
interesante el apoyo que va a brindar a
bailén que en esta convención pues lo
estamos viendo que se está rodeando de
pesos pesados dentro del partido que le
van a dar ese empuje que necesita para
llegar a vencer al presidente de donald
trabe en las elecciones del 3 de
noviembre ha estado interesante ver
también cómo además de lo que decía mi
compañera diana sobre economía también
se ha puesto de manifiesto una parte más
al que no habíamos visto quizá ayer una
parte más personal del candidato para
conocerle desde otra perspectiva y bueno
mañana va a ser una jornada todavía más
interesante mañana escucharemos a
hillary clinton escucharemos también a
otros personajes destacados dentro del
partido también nancy pelosi y será
desde luego el turno el miércoles de la
candidata a la vicepresidencia kamala
harris a la que hemos escuchado poco en
estos dos días así que es verdad que por
fin al final a jill biden como buena
primera o futura primera dama en caso de
que salga su marido yo bailé
seleccionado pues la ha nombrado y bueno
y veremos a ver cómo se desarrolla la
jornada pero ha sido desde luego muy
interesante se han tocado temas que ayer
no vimos y que posiblemente pues mañana
podremos concretar muy bien pues muchas
gracias mamen sala corresponsal de
france 24 en nueva york por sus
puntuales comentarios y sus reportes
constantes y también finalizamos con el
corresponsal de france 24 en los ángeles
mauricio cárdenas nos estaba vidente
no mamen sal a nuestra corresponsal en
nueva york' de que este día también se
abordaron temas internacionales
refiriéndose por supuesto a la región
latinoamericana que para algunos
republicanos ya le preguntaremos a
nuestro estratega republicano puede ser
señalado como un fallo y el poco
protagonismo que tuvo kamala harris
mauricio cárdenas platícanos un poco más
entonces de cómo ves esta situación de
la vicepresidenta si puede ser criticado
como lo fue el día de ayer que michelle
obama no le incluyó en su discurso y
también una breve conclusión
claro que sí me parece que es un serio
problema y una falla garrafal de estos
mensajes grabados el mensaje de michelle
obama grabado que no da cifras exactas
de la pandemia precisamente porque
logrado hace ocho días no habla de
kamala harris la senadora californiana
ahora candidata a la vicepresidencia de
eeuu no parece que ese es un serio
problema y también del tema
internacional mañana aún un día especial
para nosotros los californianos por
tener a dos personas ligadas
directamente y acá
protagonistas de esta campaña la
senadora
pelosi de california nancy pelosi además
speaker de house que también me imagino
va a hablar de la convención y por ahí
le tirará una que otra pulla o
comentario al presidente de donaldson
pues ha sido una de sus mayores críticas
y también tiene a la vicepresidenta de
la fórmula by being a cámara harles que
ha dejado vacante su lugar en el senado
y que es justamente senadora por
california posiblemente una de ellas 2
a tocar la relación con méxico
california tienen frontera con méxico y
es un socio económico aliado estratégico
que también genera muchos votos con los
mexicoamericanos así es de que yo creo
que mañana un día especial repito para
un estado que vota demócrata
tradicionalmente como lo es california y
no podríamos terminar el día de hoy con
este tema polémico parece que yo vaivén
no pronuncia bien al final y no se sabe
si dice que es mi en mí es o soy el
esposo de hielo soy el esposo de joe
entonces ya twitter está obviamente lo
que he sido con esta nueva polémica que
mantiene lo la mala fama del candidato
demócrata de algunos problemas a la hora
de hablar o equivocaciones en fin
polémica para redes sociales asciende
que terminamos de manera perfecta la
noche diría de la noche californiana
saludos para todos ustedes muy bien
mauricio ahí se notó que estaba en vivo
pues muchas gracias mauricio cárdenas
corresponsal de france 24 en los ángeles
y muchas gracias a todos los
corresponsales por su excelente trabajo
tenemos unos minutitos entonces para
despedirnos con un análisis
de nuestros especialistas empezamos
entonces con el republicano el estratega
politólogo julio schilling julio muchos
temas poco tiempo para analizarlos pero
tú ya nos estaba mencionando de que se
le puede señalar como negativo a la
jornada del día de hoy una de las cosas
que aquí se están mencionando
constantemente es por ejemplo que
alexandre a ocasio corteza ya ha hablado
y mostrado su apoyo para bernie sanders
así estaba cerrando tu pronunciamiento
anterior otro de los puntos que
seguramente dará de qué hablar es el
poco protagonismo de kamala harris te
escucha pues como no primero de alto doy
las gracias a ti y al equipo profesional
de france 24 por esta oportunidad de en
este año que en esta noche quisiera
lanzar como una nota d
de objeción pero con la idea de
alimentar el debate de ideas es la
noción de progresista o sea progresista
que ha sido secuestrado ese concepto por
por la izquierda sobre todo la izquierda
radical el socialismo no es progreso o
sea el socialismo más de 100 millones de
muertos penuria es no es progreso
entonces pues creo que eso hay que
entender yo creo del progreso y para
nada soy comunista y la idea también que
hay que entender de lo que es
nacionalismo económico o sea el
presidente de trump sin lugar a duda
igual que hubo muchos demócratas en el
pasado habrá salvación del nacionalismo
económico en otras palabras favorecer
las industrias nacionales y la
contrapartida de eso es el globalismo
eso hay que entender que son puntos
hasta filosóficos de la cual se debe
debatir y de cual la sociedad pues
democráticamente elige y de eso se trata
es incierto que el presidente es trump y
en los eeuu bajo su gobierno no ha
entrado en acuerdos
con acuerdos bilaterales o
multilaterales acuerdos multilaterales
obedeces a la noción globalista que de
nuevo van totalmente contrario a su
postura ideológica y la de otras
personas y mira por último si hay un
partido que se ha distanciado desde su
esencia ha sido el partido demócrata
tristemente que está totalmente
secuestrado por la ala izquierda ese
partido de truman de semnan ya no existe
o sea ha muerto
tristemente ojalá quiera dios ese
partido resurge y que se echa al lado
del lado izquierdo y el alexandra ocasio
cortes es decir en efecto representa
quien está en manos y dirigiendo ese
partido
tristemente ojalá que los votantes
demócratas rechacen el formato actual y
busquen en lo que fue en otra época el
partido
muy bien muchas gracias julio feeling
por tus análisis estratega republicano
muy puntual el politólogo ya me
despediré de los tres analistas al final
vamos ahora con rafael piñero es que él
es el especialista en relaciones
internacionales enfocado más que nada en
problemas políticos contemporáneos es
por ello que le quiero preguntar cómo
resume desde su área de expertise la
jornada del día de hoy y que se viene en
adelante trompo aumentará sus ataques
contra by denny contra sus piñatas
favoritas como méjico para ganar votos o
byd en empezar a atacar más duro a trump
por su manejo de la pandemia te
escuchamos
ya es oficial joe biden es el candidato
del partido demócrata para enfrentar al
presidente en ejercicio
donald trump por las elecciones del 2020
es un hecho incontestable y asimismo
refleja lo que tal vez yo vaivén a lo
largo de su carrera ha querido
transmitir y lo trataron de transmitir
las demás personas que hablaron en
nombre de es una buena persona es una
buena con persona comprometida con el
servicio público sabe liderar entiende
los problemas de la gente común y quiere
darle solución a ese tipo de problemas
hicimos un énfasis y un recorrido en
temas que hoy para el americano promedio
son significativamente importantes
empleos y salud porque porque se
convierten en dos de los más importantes
desafíos que hoy atraviesan los eeuu
cómo vamos a superar la crisis del coi
19 desde una perspectiva de salud y cómo
vamos a recuperar los millones de
puestos de trabajo que se han venido
perdiendo a pesar de que las cifras han
repuntado no necesariamente reflejan
y la economía en su conjunto lo haga de
manera efectiva así bien al final de la
jornada
vimos una tradición que se ha
consolidado y es la de que la esposa del
candidato de unas palabras de optimismo
y sin duda alguna eso fue lo que
trataron de transmitir a través de las
plataformas digitales en
significativamente difícil trataron de
ser su mejor esfuerzo y vamos a ver si
eso es suficiente para que yo vaya y
salga elegido presidente de los eeuu
gracias rafael piñero por tus constantes
análisis el especialista en relaciones
internacionales sus puntuales
comentarios y también concluimos con
rodolfo pogo analista político y
estratega demócrata por supuesto que
impresiones te deja en menos de un
minuto me quedan 40 segunditos rodolfo
discúlpame por el tiempo la jornada de
hoy
gracias a alan por la invitación quiero
saludar a ambos analistas a piñero y así
link al igual que los corresponsales
gracias por permitiendo este espacio y
poder explicarle a la población
americana porque bailes en la mejor
recogen cya en las próximas elecciones
presidenciales
el día de hoy refuerza en las palabras
de ayer de michelle obama y todo lo que
se presentó ayer aquí estamos en busca
de un liderazgo en un país que ha
perdido su rumbo su propósito sus
valores en la percepción internacional
de quiénes somos y que podemos ser la
estabilidad sobre todo pero más allá la
esperanza del mundo ya no lo somos somos
el gran agresor y es el agresor
innecesario porque no tiene fundamentos
ni sociales ni humanos ni tampoco
políticos hoy concluimos con una muy
buena noticia
bailén es el candidato ya del partido
demócrata rodolfo todo muchas gracias el
estratega demócrata y así concluimos
este especial de noticias en francés 24
con la principal conclusión de esta
segunda jornada de la convención es que
el partido ya confirmó oficialmente la
candidatura de joe biden
presidencia de eeuu de cara a los
comicios del próximo 3 de noviembre en
los que junto a kamala harris aspira a
derrotar a donald trump y como se
esperaba by del logro del apoyo de 3 mil
558 delegados frente a los mil 15 mil
151 perdón que obtuvo el senador bernie
sanders muchas gracias a nuestros
invitados aquí en pantalla muchas
gracias a los corresponsales y sobre
todo muchas gracias a ustedes siga con
más mucho más en francés 24
[Música]